[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
around what's going on
talk to me right click checking levels
making sure the good what is going on
Zach Rowley what's up John Wolf what's
going on you know how the level
five zero what's going on hustling
motivated my guy what's going on
Williams Langston [__] what's up Riley
what's going on Lloyd Metroid Nintendo
switches it into the building I turn
myself up a little bit all right all
right
we can get that popping
get these levels right
[Music]
yeah yeah what about now
what about now that's right I see I see
the switch is up I see I see
what's going on and I show lined up you
know what I mean Zoe Burke switch game
okay okay we ready we ready
[Music]
No Doubt
deck Hub in the building okay
no doubt the cattle was going on salute
salute yeah man we got a good one we
gotta go we know that teens is out here
and then of course we got my mad inside
game about to pull up real quick
trying to get a situation together
uh yeah I can hear the people can hear
you too
[Music]
Joe Mack the OG was going on without no
doubt attic pulling up King coming in a
little hot so we get him so I'll be
coming up soon so yeah we're about to
get my meds my meds Todd Crews we're
gonna get him in the building inside
game and your attic's low he's gonna
turn up he's just setting up he just
literally jumped into the call so we get
we get that pop and always call it
what's going on you already know so yeah
we're gonna have a good one a lot of
topics some fun stuff wait hold on
Takata local finally on days at work so
I can watch the streams no doubt thank
you also yeah we're gonna turn we're
going to turn attic up no doubt well I'm
low
what now you sounding better when you
always when you first come and you're
always like
oh and then you talk I'm not talking
loud yeah that's how you do it and then
always cold like he's ready for the Xbox
series hey okay the Asus Ally right I
like that I like what we doing IMAX
what's going on Kevin Baldwin what's up
no doubt all right
the legend himself you know what I mean
it's our tools and then uh yeah he's
gonna have a good show planned up and we
will be back
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff all
right that was funny I gotta come back
that's the motivator creatine boys in
the building I saw you on Twitter asking
about creatine I was laughing he's like
yo is that better legal stuff
don't play me
yo so far so good I mean I haven't
played enough to give my real expert
opinion but um yeah we'll let the the
people who got the most hours talked but
so far so good you already know but I
had to go back to a Hustler movie that
was hilarious creatine boys in the
building all right we'll be back I don't
listen with Chad Robin Kelly 201 happy
Big Lake day boy Whoa
building now he outside he outside yeah
I saw you hustle he's like is this
illegal
I'll be back
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
Sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just to Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my CD but
I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
um
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard a boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell an Uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start it regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social or my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
making Voltron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you with messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the flame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain uses a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if you fly if you're
still a mosquito you swear you ain't
nothing but really be Stevo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if you really was that
joke King David still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
listen to your all right we live by the
way bikes are hot bikes are hot let's go
kick out here messing me up yeah yeah my
bad my bad guys are not coming into
music and um ain't none of that today
bro yeah yeah yeah no demonetization
happening today
my check right quick Alex give me a
quick back check right because just to
switch over so make sure we good can you
hear me yeah yeah yeah bikes are hot and
all that kind of low he's a little low
yeah he's a little larger I'm low no now
you're good
no doubt no doubt all right hear ye hear
ye and we are live happy matriarchs day
shout out to all the brothers in the
realm on this glorious day that we
holding it down for y'all and welcome to
the iron Lords podcast LLC and also live
on lordsofgaming.net episode number
304. this is another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's date I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got the Rog
Ally pre-order revealed Zelda
tears of the Kingdom switch console
sales and Playstation showcase rumors to
discuss so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord whose passion
has an insightful and diversified
content creator has truly been a fun
personality to watch
whether it be his gaming new shorts or
hilarious Clips all done with positivity
and upholding that healthy gamer
lifestyle
introducing the Creator and host of the
Insight gaming news Tick Tock and
YouTube channel plus respected veteran
of our Air Force National Guard
the Lord of horror games and play
carrier vests advocate for playing more
than one game with the most epic
mustache in the game
I'm from Michigan and kind enough to
make his debut into the realm of the
Lord my man Lord Todd Cruz of inside
gaming how we doing sir man I'm doing
really good and uh that was that was
quite the intro you must stay up all
night writing that one I put a little
bars together for you put a little bars
together for you what's going on man
nothing much dude is enjoying this
beautiful it's a beautiful Sunday here
in Michigan I don't know where you guys
are all at but it's we're just sunny
days so nice terrible day to be in the
dungeon but a great day since you guys
all invited me out here uh what's love
brother no doubt always a pleasure to
see you got a chance to bump with you
two times recently but since then has
what's the games man what you been
playing man man you know what's funny is
I actually just Dove back into Eldon
ring a few days ago and I have just been
I I I just got my butt handed to me by
the godskin dude I don't know how
familiar where you guys are yeah
they know and if you confirming he's
crazy yeah yeah they rough that was one
of the because I used to jump in on like
the lfg and help people uh the uh that
was one of the most requested helps that
I think I've ever done
that's that's crazy to hear too but like
I'm just glad that there's other people
that have suffered with me because it's
better to suffer in the team
sit
let me cook let me cook oh man no doubt
you already know we got lots of stuff I
got so mad at those guys that I I went
and dove in after them solo so I went
and killed that one and then I went
killed the skinny one and I was like
yeah I can handle you guys solo you
ain't nothing crazy
yeah that's what I've been playing the
most of lately uh I've been uh Trucking
through
um redfall and what else have I been
playing gosh I should pull up my steam
library and see what I even have with
scholar okay we should be rocking well
you know what I play a ton of though I'm
not gonna lie I was never a player of
this game and my entire life and then
they drop no build mode I'm talking
about fortnite I don't know that's my
guy oh you know kicking you was besties
down now that's right no build mode
that's right stand up I go first you
know what took them so long to do that
but it was the most brilliant move yes
win in the game as far as it goes to
battle royales everyone else needs to
stop competing because they ain't look I
had to bend the knee I was I was I was
one of them hating I was like a pub G
dude I was hating and then it it's just
Unstoppable man and the key for me is
what you said once the no build more
because the worst thing you'd be
fighting somebody you just build a house
yeah you like come on man but like once
they got rid of that and then I'm not
gonna front the promotional though the
things they do in that world and the cat
it's just you can't stop them there's
anime stuff and then they got me with
the destiny stuff and Silver Surfer as a
comic geek and I'm like yeah they got me
but [__] play in that and that
ecosystem is nuts it's crazy yeah it's
just saying no doubt you know what's
funny is universally they just cater to
every fan base in the entire world and
it's also awesome marketing for anyone
that wants to get their game out there
or Dragon Ball Z right yeah they
promoted Dragon Ball super in the movie
coming out by dropping Dragon Ball Z
characters you know and people want to
be like oh this isn't fortnite anymore
it used to be regular characters it's
like why are you hating yeah
uh the event where they had the Dragon
Ball Z event and you was able to watch
the whole uh cartoons yep in in the
stadium did you get a chance to uh the I
think his name is kid Lodi uh go to go
to the concert for kid Lodi I don't
think so no I I did watch the DBZ
episodes but I'd do a concert all right
so when you go in he's still probably
there right now just going to creative
and you're going to go to an interactive
concert which is mind-boggling to me
because his music is dope and I was
listening to his music before now I
actually get a chance to see the guy I'm
like it's real good how do you do it
you'll love it yo this hilarious cake yo
you know how like Sid used to tease me
because I'll be acting like an old head
I don't like Tick Tock because he would
take that oh she did he like yo I follow
this dude on Tick Tock
I was like see I'm getting better
already yeah I said you see sick we got
Tick Tock yes now what's up
oh we got the guns out the guns is out
the guys away
y'all are crazy he is crazy
together it's crazy ridiculous
gotta bring them gamer gangs outside
yeah pretty much I mean I'm looking
right here I play I'm a huge Resident
Evil fan so I always have Resident Evil
installed I actually just got Resident
Evil Village on br oh man and the svr
too oh my god dude you know listen
there's some uh what's it called uh
hesitations behind that and I was like
yeah it's an expensive piece of hardware
and I totally get it like that's
expensive to be playing VR but it's like
it's so Niche right yeah I'm happy to be
blessed enough to where like I could
afford one and try it out and be like
you know what I could see why people
would be mad about a piece of equipment
like this because it's expensive and
it's like I already played this game
regular is it really that much better in
VR the answer is yes
God bless you yeah God bless you oh it's
terrifying I built for that I ain't
built for it I'm a grown man but I ain't
built I love the experience
but I just you can't have any idiots
around it that's it man yeah man you
know
like attic when you play
remember what addicted that to your
package oh man I was like come on man
I'm gonna put his hand on my shoulder
while you was over there when we was
playing demio that's right yeah yeah
Todd rolled up that's what time roll up
then yeah you got scared and Demon
[Laughter]
Brooklyn in the building he's a psvr he
said yeah that Resident Evil Village is
dope he co-sized with Todd talk about
you know what I'm saying but yeah I bet
we gonna get into it you already know
what actually yeah we got the four
horsemen and gaming those original Lords
are the realm here in the round table my
co-host the co-host my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his old world and the
how often young wolf what a man Lord
addict daddy addict show how we doing
sir
doing pretty good I was playing pretty
much was out all morning
tears of the Kingdom you uh right now is
definitely feeling like mad like breath
of the wildish I don't think that's like
a bad thing or anything but I would say
that like some of these skills are
interesting man some of these skills are
interesting I don't like you call them
and keep reminding me your call because
you keep putting the pressure on my neck
because you know I was coming in hating
a little bit before before it released
so he's like come I'm telling everybody
say it it's the game
oh like I'd appreciate all them calls
this week man I'm just letting you know
[Music]
and of course we have our technical
gaming Lord the solo game who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Davis the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man PC Master races on Lord
Sovereign
so Friday right I'm like Friday I'ma sit
down I'm gonna play the other old damn
day at work that's just what I'm gonna
do
we have five people out mind you they
only have 10 people on my shift five
people out but but the funny thing is
right you would think and I'm I'm I'm
kind of like cards now right so the
thing is so I'm like okay when you have
that many people out the opposite
happens when you think oh it's gonna be
a whole lot of work say no now with that
few that few people on on schedule it's
like you know what we're only dealing
with absolute extreme emergencies other
than that don't call me I don't do
anything leave me alone I'm like I'm
gonna sit down and play hours
through hours I got through the I to
this moment I got through the damn intro
bro I'm like this come on man this is
this hate hate hate hate say they have
to be done on Saturday I'm just like I'm
trying that was the day I dedicated
fulfilling everything and everybody kept
bothering or something kept going wrong
and I had to literally stop what I'm
doing but continue I know where you at
that was it so I said nothing I'm
through the intro the only thing I I
could say about the intro is that yes
that little in the beginning right they
start telling you a little bit about the
background whatever and I'm looking at
it and I'm like I'm like King is
Justified now okay because this is all
about Sky people and I'm like oh my God
okay
it's Justified we're going to save the
bars don't save them yeah yeah that's I
mean that's what that's all I know I
don't know
other than that that's been there
because obviously other than that like I
got to I got to patch the update to to
oh Jedi Survivor I took time I took day
to patch the game to patch the game it
runs beautifully now so that's good it's
already 150 gigabytes what was it
another 10 gigabytes for the patch yeah
pretty much you know how that goes it's
like why don't you reinstall the whole
game again why don't you do that like
I'm just like you know what whatever but
all right Call of Duty Junior yes
I can't I can't even I can't even say
anything right now look at me I I jumped
on I jumped on head first in the worst
possible moment when it was like nah PC
every single version of every single
game coming out is absolute trash all
right there we go
there we go let's go
I'm excited because I'm getting my TV at
the end of this week so again what's the
big spending let me let me pack a
Samsung s95c QD OLED okay there we go
and oh this is it has been dubbed the
best gaming TV ever hold on hold on did
they do about people who do the review
though dude what's up ratings everybody
yeah he's he's top test he's up there so
I'm excited the TV beat my TV son
although I Gotta Give it to uh uh the
the G3 okay the um the LG because they
it's still a regular what they call Wall
lead right a regular OLED so the
technology is a different but they have
something called a micro lens array MLA
in it now that kind of brightens them it
up okay and so it if it fights it fights
with the community LG's in the building
okay yeah but LG's they're gonna have to
jump to to qdon at some point because
the brightness you're talking about
brightness levels that are like close to
LED TVs
um or up there with them I honestly so
it's like when you have like the perfect
blacks of an OLED plus that the
brightness it's kind of Bonkers you know
how you do with your perfect blacks your
video file this is annoying bro you're
like the perfectionist with that eat
that black look a little gray yeah he'll
come over here he'll come over and like
just like disrespect your team yeah
this is a I already I already have a
friend that straight up does that okay
yeah being him do not see eye to eye
when it comes to monitors yes because
I'm Still rocking I got 27 inch Asus
1080p monitors and that's what I play
that's why I play Elder ring on and I'm
like oh this game looks gorgeous and my
friends like it looks like poop
so this is my thing right I'm never
gonna shame somebody for resolution
never never it's about it's about
accuracy it's about right right exactly
exactly but it's true like I'm not I'm
resolution is never the the thing right
it pisses me off about resolution with
consoles and stuff like that right yeah
it's frame rate and when it comes to
accuracy accuracy of colors and and and
the difference between light and dark if
you got that right I don't care what
you're playing but if you don't if you
don't that's all how bougie are we that
when we go to somebody's house in a TV
gaming up to Paul you don't even sit
down
you stand close to the door like yeah
that's nice
I'll tell you this so I'm sound like he
repping TCL no no no sir no Stitch
trying to get you Stitch not at all sir
I still got a box TV that's what I plan
oh you're ready to go you play with the
big back big back bubble face let's go
big back TV when they look like
furniture
jokes
I got nice TVs
like I have the uh I have the LG Ultra
gear 48 OLED okay I have my PlayStation
5 hooked up to that and I play all my
single player games on there and I'm
like spoiled rotten baby when because I
got that monitor to sit up on this wall
right now
poopy monitors right here
pocket watches there's a lot a lot of a
lot of money flying around
you must be doing inside gaming boy I'm
in severe credit card debt I'm talking
about you over there somebody help me
this week no doubt and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the the
XS came out the prophet of Xbox Swami
King of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Hold the Line Lord King how are
we doing sir merch coming soon yes all
right don't don't worry about it
don't worry that merch is coming this
one I hope the merch would have been
there by uh Friday but it looks like
it's going to get there today and it'll
definitely be there by uh this weekend
um Rollie Romero versus barbaros oh that
was a fight last night I wasn't gonna
cover that fight he fought a 40 year old
man off a two-day notice okay I was not
covering that one I was not doing that
fight yesterday was it was not gonna be
worth my time well it turns out oh boy
started putting the Beats on rolly oh he
was putting beats on rolly from round
one oh uh so rolly knocked him down in
the ninth round oh landed a flurry of
punches and the referee stopped to fight
the worst controversial uh stoppage that
I've seen in a long time this is the
reason why uh you know it turned so many
people away from boxing that is the
exact reason why and um I was just
disheartened to see it but the belt was
on the line and they're talking big
money with him fighting Ryan Garcia next
so God bless
um
I gotta address something oh
man what's up where we going you see you
see the gazelles is coming off oh it's
real always okay
I gotta address and do so when you see
me take out
uh what is these These are Grand Masters
okay okay so when you see me take these
out that's different I want you to go
check that price oh all right um let's
get him
now when I put out content it's for
y'all to consume any way you choose and
I don't really care you can do it good
you could joke clown me I saw people
doing videos it was funny to me I had a
good time I was like oh yeah hold the
line went viral bro we broke the
internet with that
dude just making jokes it was it was so
funny how creative some people are in
this community it's beautiful yes but
then it was one dude somebody sent me a
message it was one dude that I saw the
video
and I was like I know you ain't talking
about me oh yeah
[Music]
Otis oh that's just in case you didn't
know who I'm talking to I wasn't gonna
do it to you because you had one single
fan left and he was in our uh he left a
message in that video
he was still Champion you and I saw you
sitting there
looking like something wrong with you
like you having a mental breakdown oh
man and um
you talking about you squabbling in
these streets nobody heard of your
fights oh no we do it they forgot about
you
oh man we doing this I'm Gonna Keep it a
buck with you I got receipt I got so
many receipts it's crazy but let me tell
you why I'm so upset with you okay I'm
gonna tell you why I'm piecing around no
piece of the room right no it's always
peace
you think that I start problems no I'm
just so comfortable when problems come
they don't bother me so it looks like I
started it oh
but you did
we don't lead with disrespect we leave
factual factual at all times I think
every man deserves respect fact so you
was never on our radar there was never
anybody to be concerned about he was
never anybody to talk about you are has
been in a forgotten
but let me tell you why
you were disingenuous to the people that
was watching
you act like you ain't know who we were
oh man when I got direct receipts you
working with my comrades oh man we do it
you know exactly who the hell we are you
remember when Larry Holmes said Rocky
Marciano couldn't hold his jock strap
yes Classic live you can't hold my job
oh but your style ain't nice oh he can't
buy no don't do this at no point in time
can you touch me and I saw you trying to
get in your bag and it looked like old
boy in the club with the bad moves your
moves is garbage oh my God we doing this
the reason why
you're a fraud you're a liar and you're
a cheat gonna quit
it would have been dope
see because it's good to rep something
when it's going good Xbox One 360. oh
you was outside
the Heat hit you with Xbox One era
you dip you dropped your flag
you turn tail now you're a trophy for
the other dudes the other dudes look at
you you're a trophy they bring you out
like a marionette puppet when they want
to show what they captured
you have been captured I can't believe
we doing this and I'm telling you I this
is the reason why if you would have just
held the line
if you would have held the line we
showed up in the Xbox One era
could you imagine how dope it could have
been
you need your tag team in the situation
I got your back you got my back
I said something to inspire people you
took that inspiration and turned it into
contempt and that contempt turned into
jealousy and hate and then that video
that's all I saw then you try to tell
your comrades that was sitting next to
you to join in with you
not knowing that your comrade is my
comrade not knowing that he knows I'm
real
you're made up and I'm a made man oh man
oh man it's a difference
so the next time you want to pull that
little stocking cap over your head roll
it up and stuff it in your mouth and go
sit down in the corner and be quiet
don't bring my podcast name in your
mouth again let's leave it at that peace
and love peace and love y'all
I don't like to do that early in the day
especially on Mother's Day
I gotta wait a whole week
dudes act up on Monday
oh man look man I I I got that to say on
that type of stuff I don't give that
negative no negativity
you know obviously I don't know it
pissed me off the most when he was
bothering my cousin nah it's all good
it's all good listening it's positivity
brother at the end of the day look if
people enjoy what we doing and and our
name is in the title at the end of the
day clearly what you did inspired a lot
of people right or some level creatively
right that's how I look at it so yeah
like I said if that's the case you don't
say that he came out and be like I know
the dudes I work with them
I kept it real yeah a lot of people yeah
it ain't no B for that like that it's
just the manufactured stuff but I
understand where you come from it's the
manufacturing stuff you know I ain't
with all that you know that kind of
stuff and look God bless do your thing
if that God gets you more content for
being disrespectful do you think you
know what I'm saying so what I was
playing so what you
on Christmas
you know when you get your Darth Maul
you just sit there and I was putting him
through every emote that I had I was
like go Darth Maul go Darth Maul
and I put a lot of zesty uh dances but
um
Zelda tears of the Kingdom yeah yeah
all morning morning I'm just gonna say
chef's kiss oh Jeff's kiss
a lot of that that's it that's all I've
been playing you know I've been trying
to jump back into destiny
that's a full-time job man
there ain't no casual Destiny done
factual here we go and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
Lord Cognito spread that real into the
Roman IOP not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to Define shout out to Mr Maddie plays
had a good one talking about the
Starfield situation or the latest
updates showcase all that good stuff yo
shout out to my homie ebontist he just
came off the uh surgery I had that
deviated septum you're gonna be all
right brother you're gonna be good oh
he'd be part of the click now yeah all
three of us
you know what I'm saying breathe easy so
salute to that and then uh Travis will
be back so we'll be back to talk uh
full-time Destiny as Tyler said on that
show um that'll be next week a lot of
exotic changes and I believe season of
The Deep the uh marketing material went
out for that so we get that stop
laughing kick
stop laughing today
anyway uh they named it like out there
that's what they they did it is what it
is no [__] obviously we'll talk about
Zelda
um Midnight Sun storm DLC oh my Lord
this is amazing yeah like I at first I
remember when the announcement of the
character like how's she gonna fit
midnight Suns now obviously they got
some X-Men they got Wolverine they got
all magic but she fits like a glove in
this game then the old voice actress
from icora from Destiny 2 I believe is
voices I'm pretty sure it's her she
sounds powerful the cinematics are great
stay tuned in the room we got something
cooking stay tuned we got something
cooking with midnight we got some stay
tuned but yeah it's phenomenal I got
something cooking where I have to
actually go play that game yes you need
to go play sir so oh yeah so midnight
Suns is lit and then um I ain't going
fronts off
has been all tekking cause my meds are
Reagan yeah
I was like finally okay okay it looked
like it changed a little bit a lot of
bayak a lot of a lot of bayek right yeah
throw a lot of you know that old shadow
fight energy your kung fu is good yeah
exactly like kayak by X moves are always
like tighter more range zero wears
whereas meringue seemed like it was a
tongue taller character yeah
he's tight though like oh my goodness
bro we've got a lot of moves that are
mid-checks yes big checks the flows you
know I saw the punch reversals oh man
like I'm really loving the
transformation the only issue because
shout out to your brother being your
brother yourself your brother called me
yeah because he's like yo and at first I
wasn't feeling not that I wasn't feeling
the suit I didn't like the traditional
suit on a motorbike
don't wear the gear yeah
[Music]
listen I don't care what nobody talk
about y'all not seeing that Unreal
Engine do you see these faces yeah
it's crazy what Tekkit is doing right
now salute to harada the team and uh
it's allow salute to um they did his
review because I was I was hating I was
like how's Lily a hell about me how's
all these people ahead of my man but
what they did is they saved it for a
regional release in Korea so the Korean
fan base was going crazy for that man it
was just a beautiful thing so salute to
that and uh played uh sorry to be proud
of me after the redfall situation I I
finally got to listen to the episode of
Duke so I I'm assuming you're playing
one of the goats right now I thought
y'all was capping I ain't gonna front I
thought y'all arcade stands was capping
[Music]
um
this is like yo it's tell me it's not
one of the greatest stealth games bro
you know we come what we call it Mercury
murder American murder murder
and like the way you can handle the
situation just you could grab somebody
up get the [__] choke them out throw
them like dab him in the neck oh like
I'm missing from redfall bro I knew it
was different as soon as I jumped out
this the uh did the prison escape and
the guards actually had Corner vision
and we're talking I'm like get ego
yeah and then you were like and then you
were like oh I can crawl on this pipe up
here and then I can find my way and then
you haven't even so you just started you
haven't uh just like two missions a lot
of those no I got the spiritual pot with
Detroit that's teleport it's got this
mystical aspect yeah legendary
Coralville skill like I see y'all which
I talk about the skill tree like yeah
we're gonna get today because we go
along but I had to give arcade their
flowers I'm like hey this was
[Music]
one of the things I love about like
Dishonored is like the World building
like yeah you go through there you find
out what happened and you're not at the
very beginning of where like you go up
that they put you in like this thing and
they pour water in it and it raises your
boat like eventually you have to go back
there and like you see like it's like
reminisce is like oh man this is where
everything went down like you know what
I'm saying
it's good man it's good and you know uh
it there's a there's actually an
achievement beating the whole game
without killing one yes I have I have it
and I love stuff like that because it's
a it's a call back to the classic
stealth games because yeah okay the
people you're assassinating there
there's like ways to there's hard way
harder ways than just go in there and
kill them yeah but they're there's ways
that you can do every mission in that
game and every assassination Target
where you don't kill them
you'll make them like confess what they
did right that's fine or you could do
stuff like this one dude that I remember
specifically like you could kill him
right and and sort of he eliminated his
influence or you could do you don't even
have to kill him you can knock him out
and like put him on a ship that's
leaving the dock and he'll be gone right
so wait it's stuff like that that like
it really when I look at restful I'm
like what what yeah it's it's Dishonored
it's through Jersey what can't even talk
about this Dishonored and like I said I
I mean this honored 2 is good too like a
lot of people I know people there's a
lot of people that think like the first
one's better but I really enjoyed the uh
dishonor too what's funny is when you do
like you know like your powers and
dishonor yeah like there's a at the very
beginning of a Dishonored tooth like do
you want to play the whole game without
The Outsiders Powers I'm like no
wow that's an added challenge but yeah I
see it what was also underrated was the
combat like I really liked the whole gun
with the knife and the block and I I
didn't expect that it was it's really
tight man so salute to them and 60 FPS
on the uh backup I believe on that and I
was maybe going back got another convert
and just converted we just converted
shout out to Maddie shout out to my my
co-host Mr Valley plays he's been
preaching a good word this is redemption
Arc no doubt he was always on this yeah
they did that so that's been pretty much
it would be okay I'm sorry that's what I
was saying like I was hoping redfall
would be like mad successful because I
don't want anything to happen Arcane
before they can read it with that
franchise because the fact that they
combined it like they like the
developers said that death Loops in the
same universe is Dishonored so they're
gonna do something with that franchise
eventually because it's like you can you
could tell people who didn't realize it
it literally blink has the same
animations the same color everything
they're like there's no reason why you
wouldn't think both of those are in the
same universe yeah no doubt salute to
the team you already know Sovereign
yes absolutely let's do that
um we got
hustle and motivate two dollar Super
Chat the creatine boys in the building
great team boys you already know it's
funny he's on Twitter it's like it's
creatine illegal I'm like yeah bro you
have to make sure that was like salute
the hustle during this uh Fitness day
yes sir there we go Robert kellett two
dollars stupid chat happy big link day
Lord that's my big Link in the street
everybody clear out the block
no dope we got stay high FFF two dollar
stupid chat Hold the Line whoa don't get
mad if it's viral
it's all jokes and fun y'all don't get
don't be making videos being upset I'm
upset
I refuse I'm like fairly let the room go
you know what I'm saying like let my man
eat like God oh man it was real funny to
see people legit bad at that like I was
dying like he's supposed to have his
head down yeah he's supposed to be upset
what he's supposed to be he's supposed
to be quiet he's supposed to sit down
yeah this is funny with that that was
hilarious
five dollars
Nintendo has the top three highest rated
games of all time on open critic with
tears of the Kingdom topping the list I
will be collecting tears of the haters
in the chat
get you get your balls on that's your
time
it's your time cook a little cook there
we got stay high FF I just put the crest
in the chat for stay high at that path
yes remember Lord bronze thank you
brother I appreciate that yeah
we have Robert kellett once again to a
lot of Super Chat it's amazing Nintendo
won game of the year already
got a strong already there you go hold
you and we got Robert Kelly again no no
that was not it I copied that twice
Nintendo Taco ten dollar Super Chat
Cog it's over all the Nintendo hate was
not enough to stop the nintendominance
this is DLC excuse me
if this is DLC then every developer
should be embarrassed the King has
returned he has tagged the book of n oh
the [__] okay listen man I gotta I
gotta play I gotta I gotta I gotta get
into it but uh now right now what
happened what happened
I hope that wasn't that uh you know how
your waiter throws you that uh yeah yeah
no you didn't notice okay okay
we got a lot to talk about we gonna get
into it but yeah the people in the realm
seem to agree that it is transformative
yes it is then we have gaming for Tay
ten dollar Super Chat there's only one
game in this time of tyranny that can
bring Gamers together Zelda is such a
title I pity blind console Warriors that
distract themselves from sharing in this
momentous occasion this moment this
occasion that was an event man you know
how I know [__] is corruptable
how is Zelda not the number one topic on
this thing oh see see no no no he
flipped it because I'm Charlie thank you
you're gonna try to stop propaganda
already don't know the thing okay even
though I'm probably gonna stay for most
of Zelda but that's the only reason
because I literally looked out for my
men's on Mother's Day who said yo I
might not be able to stay the whole Joy
so I said yo we gonna push your topic to
the front since I want to get your boss
and that's it but Zelda was these
Nintendo fans so emotional I love it yo
how come it's your
you before the show I don't see any
Nintendo topics this year
but we have Xbox podcast yeah but we had
Xbox podcast okay okay guys continue we
got Dragonheart Yobe remember for 22
months Lord gold hashtag peace love life
keep up the great work Lords David I
left you some goodies on fortnite man
enjoy speak it into existence there will
be an iron Lords podcast live in front
of a big crowd I see it yo yo words
facts
and we have Sith Lord remember for nine
months Lord bronze happy Mother's Day to
all the Lords mothers and their wives
absolutely thank you thank you you guys
wouldn't be as good as you are without
your better half keeping up the great
works
then we've got Necromancer zail remember
for 18 months Lord gold got my Asus Rog
I pre-ordered can't wait until June 13th
we'll be using it with my ILP valari ah
let's get it let's talk about blessings
everyone
got the Villari pillows all the pillows
is shipped if anybody was waiting for
those pillows to start shipping before
they ordered Now's the Time to jump in
and if you're overseas we got that
connect too covered everybody's covered
now yeah you should be getting all your
stuff in a timely fashion even if you
order now salute
and we got Spartan go 17 two pound Super
Chat King sliding on the Block tap
dancing with dracles yeah he pulled up
today
that's what happens when you got a week
to think I was gonna say something nice
too
get him King
[Laughter]
don't let that go evil evil kid came
outside today
we have Marvin ginyard two dollars if we
chat let's save the Uganda knee length
trouser snake
I don't know about the Charles mistake
we are not doing that but hit the like
button though hit the like button I
don't know if we're saving this
particular animal we appreciate the
donation we'll make sure it gets to the
proper you know organization I don't
know about trousers
[Laughter]
come on
then we have four IQ no more no less
okay okay
with the five euro Super Chat tears of
the Kingdom got those 30 FPS cups Cog
it's just playing much love
hey frame rate spray rate I guess here
it is what it is
good all right let me see what else we
got after that we got jumped a little
bit let me roll back we got tsws gaming
two dollars Solo
in them
tomorrow could be interesting keep
holding the line
hold the line hold the line maybe maybe
you showing up
let's see let's not pop bottles early
but let's see but when you see me
running past on Twitter tomorrow you
gonna be insufferable to deal with it
this thing turns around don't let this
thing turn around you are gonna be hard
to deal with continue yeah we have
hearty two dollars
game of the year is out tears of the
kingdom is great absolute my guy no
doubt then we got Robert Kelly once
again two dollars Super Chat Starfield
gonna match tears of the goat we'll see
we'll see they got it already beats him
in resolution
Savage
unless you're playing it someplace else
I got my receipt though don't come after
me yeah
mine is digital
project Aries two dollar Super Chat
salute to all the mothers of the round
thank you absolutely thank you guys as
well and project Aries once again ten
dollars to the chat I was listening to
DD's podcast Cog was hyped for Starfield
primarily for sexual times
the realm can fly you out to Colombia
for a week to go get it right if you
need it just say the word look man don't
get high don't get mad cause I was
excited for the you know the eslb rate
look man it's not a vanilla situation
we're gonna be doing things in space and
I'm I'm happy about it I'm not ashamed
exactly it just it reminds me of Mass
Effect
bro it sounded like they were gonna give
me Mass Effect but without no action
bro we gotta we out here it's a lonely
time we got things
my place
hey I'm having fun I'm a role playing
continue
[Music]
somebody said it said it Big Lick day
that's not what we said so nobody said
that
where does the line start and can I get
more than one ticket whoa
it's all good
PSA anyone pre-ordering The Rock Ally in
the US Best Buy has a 70 discount yes
have to use the Best Buy card to buy and
use discount code and the code is there
oh that's awesome because yeah the the
uh pre-orders are still up they're still
they're still there oh real quick I want
to give a special shout out break
protocol man doc doc 1985 in the chassis
this is an example of having fun like we
did the king to the hold the line
brother I saw your video was absolutely
hilarious we go work on something to run
with you but again it's all fun and
joking he's having fun with it you know
what I'm saying that's how we that's
what we talk about and that was a
perfect example that uh did an edit on
Twitter yeah he was using his video and
then you know yeah I just love the
creativity the Creator hey dude's having
fun we just have this is fun and that
the way he handled it was lit so salute
you that dog I did see that somebody
said that to me no doubt continue oh
yeah when you went upstairs when he went
upstairs and got the gift it was like
okay you're right I've been acting up I
gotta hold the line
gotta pause the video video she was like
would you press play yeah it was funny
it was so long that I had to make sure
the video was still going yes right
and shout out to him because if it would
have been me I'd have cut like half of
that off that he's like it don't matter
it's going no I salute to him on that
that's we just having fun man that's
what it's about good all right we got
Gerald Mack five dollar Super Chat shout
out to the iron Lords podcast in the
chat great to see everyone's salute hold
the lock hold the line exactly that's a
fun then we got black Ronin three five
seven five dollar Super Chat shout out
to the realm link is overpriced last gen
trip oh go play Diablo four
Diablo Fanboys are outside okay okay
that that's an opinion all right let's
see what's going on
that we have John Wolfe five dollar
Super Chat only Nintendo makes grown men
bend over for cardboard and mods I'm one
of them by the way
absolutely
speak your truth brother speak at you
and we are caught up all right finally
my man my bad topic patient you know
what I'm saying dealing with all our
foolishness in any way now that the
Lord's been finished up the super chats
in the business and all that good stuff
in the world we gotta finally switch our
Focus to Lord Ty this video game system
history his journey into content
creation and of course what led him to
creating the sight gaming news Tick Tock
twitch and YouTube channels so Lord Tom
let's start from the beginning man what
some of the first video game systems you
had what got you into gaming really
first I gotta I gotta match uh King's
energy here and just kind of oh
I heard that live action Gears of War
might be a thing and uh I mean I feel
like Iowa look the part a little bit I
mean let's go bro but uh no uh
I actually I when I first started my
Tick Tock Channel I was emulating Dr
disrespect heavily because one it was
actually really nice because uh I put
these on and I could just read my script
and you couldn't see where my eyes were
so yeah it's great now I don't wear them
so I have to memorize my scripts and
actually try pretty hard
no don't but I will talk about that
later uh so yeah first gaming systems
man I mean I gotta I gotta get a shout
out to Mama on Mama's day but she's the
reason I'm a gamer through and through
man she was playing the pong and stuff
like that on the Atari is the reason we
had a Nintendo original uh growing up
and we'd sit there and play Mario
forever and I would die and she would be
a God in my eyes and uh because she
wouldn't die
and uh yeah I mean that was the first
system that I could I mean I can remind
remember all the way back playing that
you know until bedtime you know
absolutely and then uh Sega Genesis uh
Super Nintendo one PlayStation two we
had it all man the only thing the only
thing I ever didn't own was a Dreamcast
um Sonic the Hedgehog one of my homies I
loved him I think Sonic claps Mario oh
oh you [__] real spicy these Nintendo
fans in here be careful be careful
that's a lot of strong Sega talk this is
their Day Tour I know Zelda just came
out and there's lots of Nintendo fans in
the chat but I'm not one to not stir the
pot all right so break it down all right
you got because this is real
controversial you know real old school
Fanboy Wars right here right so my
question is like why solid claps Barry
under you like you gotta break it down
why
so I mean Barrio is just a regular dude
light speed powers
gen versus Goku debate man Goku wins
they had um they had I think in Epic
right bat not Epic Rap Battles screw
attacks death battle I think Sonic or
Shadow face someone from the DBZ
universe or someone like strong and I
think they had him win like I can't
remember it like like people don't
realize I can't remember if he won or
not but people don't realize how strong
like if you put up like golden Sonic
compared to most characters he's gonna
he's gonna destroy them golden Sonic is
top tier that's okay probably Golden Sun
is probably one of the strongest
characters in in gaming history like
pound for pound like there's not a lot
of people that can be here all right so
what about what about movie the movie
though Mario outside what's up dude I
gotta say the representation of
SuperSonic in Sonic 2 was beautiful oh
it was so satisfying like everyone saw
it leading up to it okay and then when
it happened you were just like yes this
is what I needed to see and so sort of
live action
I can't pick either one of those I think
both of them did very well I think
exactly I think I'm leaning more towards
Sonic because even though Mario was a
fantastic movie I think I enjoyed
watching Sonic more like me personally
yeah two two different food adaptation
was pretty impressive considering they
went live action slash right like that
that was a leap yeah so you have two
different approaches uh attacking the
genre that we love and I gotta say
Nintendo did exactly they played to
their shrimps they played The Nostalgia
and you really saw everything in the
backgrounds like if you were a Nintendo
dude you remember the original name of
Donkey Kong Jump Man and you know a lot
of stuff like the you know f-zero and
all these stuff that you saw karate
champ everything was in the background
of wrestling star man everything was
there if you if you took the time out to
watch it Sonic
it represents Sonic everything is moving
so fast you got to watch the movie at
least two or three times and it's it
just they captured the speed in essence
of Sonic so I love it yeah I think part
of the reason too that I respect Sonic
so much is like they had that they had
that that
Sonic look like came straight out of a
horror movie at first remember it oh
you're talking about the original
representation is like oh no they went
back and fixed it like to me the people
who made that movie that like they they
saved the whole franchise because
absolutely be because like we always sit
there and say stuff like you know we
want to be heard they heard us they went
back they spent millions of dollars
reanimated him throughout the whole
movie and then they made it right in the
movie so it's extremely well yeah and
it's just like I love like little things
like they they show where Sonic doesn't
know what he's doing and he he's like
he's like which way is New York or
whatever the his ring shut he's like
that when he runs that when he comes
back and he thought he spits out a fish
and he's like there was water that way
salute to the blue bird you already know
okay they want me to turn you they said
turn your volume up a little bit and
we'll hear the king while you were Todd
spitting so arms we got that so um some
any questions in reference to the gaming
history as far as you know you mentioned
the Genesis pretty much had everything
mom dogs have you know pong OG's you
know what I'm saying like any questions
yeah I muted I mean there you go no fomo
for the Dreamcast whatsoever when it
when it was out because I know you said
you didn't get it but it was there was
no no form or whatsoever for it being
you know having been in like the Sega
ecosystem so I will say that I got to
miss out on one of the games my favorite
franchise uh Resident Evil I never got
to play code Veronica oh man wow and
you've never gone back to it I've never
I'll hold out for a remake oh yeah okay
you know what's gonna happen Okay
um no I mean uh I think I had a friend
that had one I got to play was it Sonic
Adventures 2 where you got the little
Chows and that was fun uh but no never
never got that one I just uh the gaming
lineup it was funny how Adept I was into
gaming even before I was even buying my
own systems I was like oh I just don't
see anything that I really care about on
this except for that Resident Evil and I
wasn't gonna buy it
I hurt someone's heart and I apologize
that's what I'm in my feelings I gotta
Look At You Like Crazy Taxi bro Go Crazy
Taxi no so look at that Soul Gallery
my first Soul Caliber game was on Xbox
three or Xbox yes one with spawn right
Xbox yeah so that was that that was that
was that that was that game right I
can't remember yeah they just uh did it
again they just did it again no no I'm
sorry yeah I'm sorry that's two yeah
with link had LinkedIn right and that's
what each console exclusive yeah
and Link was the most sought afterwards
that one's the one that was most
valuable I remember I still remember
memes weren't really a thing back then
but I remember everyone roasting the
PlayStation one they were like this is
dumb why do they get fun and Nintendo
gets link and then we get what was that
no one even knows it was hey Hachi and
the thing about heyachi so he's fighting
all these guys with weapons and all he
has is some bracers on his own
I'm like all right it did it Soul
Calibur continue to kind of lean into
that later I remember like yeah I mean
Yoda and Darth Vader yeah so who had
which one I can't remember who had your
older one had geralt recently right that
was so Calibur that was the last one
yeah
E3 that's when I was beating Gary in
that game and um I remember it but
everybody got uh geralt yes yes they
stopped the uh like the license for per
character yeah no doubt which was cool
so that was six yeah that was six and
then five was the one that had the Star
Wars characters yeah no doubt no doubt
so pretty much it's a long time every
every video game system from that point
on yeah I think I went on a PlayStation
Hiatus after PS2 I didn't get a PS3 I
had a PS4 for about 15 days and I took
it back because I know it's funny that's
what PS4 was starting to come out with
all their or I know PS3 had the you know
Last of Us came out I just put the last
of us recently oh wow what do you think
of it it was a masterpiece which one did
you play the first one the first remake
the first one remake remake okay yeah
that one looks phenomenal it looks crazy
yeah say that I am a big at and there's
a lot of people out there that say stop
making remakes make new games but it's
like some games like you can remake them
and it would just be a better experience
right so like you have the headspace
Remake that just came out right yeah
people were like in my videos that I
made they were like do I have to play
the first one first and people are
saying yeah play the first one and I was
like no absolutely not wait one it's a
one for one remake you're just gonna
experience everything the way you always
should have experienced it basically
yeah right like the first one was
definitely scary oh yeah and and then
this one just did it again more scary
yeah yeah modern technology and just it
it really just expands upon it doesn't
really change all that much man like
it's that it this should be the de facto
core experience now but the first one's
still great Capcom showed you how to do
remix yes they did yeah yeah they did
well hold on put on that which way which
way what we hold it on was it an evil 2
they did moderate Justice too right
Resident Evil 3 they should not have
done
I will say that Resident Evil 3 remake
they were probably working on four then
too and they were like let's just put
all of our assets into four and then
like 12 people can work on three like
that's because they only made of half
the game
yeah at this point like it's weird that
they've done all of these these games
it's like just go back and do one at
this point like it's because to someone
like me that didn't really dabble a
whole whole lot into one good point it's
just now since they've remade two three
four hopefully they don't go to Five
next they go back to one I doubt it but
I'm just sitting here like how you gonna
leave the one that started it all over
there by itself with the Remake you did
give a shirt they gave it a good remake
for the time yeah but it's just like
then they go to two and they just
completely change things up like if they
do that at it I hope they go back to one
of my favorites which is zero zero on
the train on the train zero gets
unappreciated and I love the Remake and
uh to answer Lord uh attic too it's like
I think the Resident Evil one remake
remaster is the staple for survival
horror even though they were tank
controls and a lot of people are
controversial about tank controls at the
same time like that created horror I
mean that was my first horror game I was
seven I didn't get to play it because I
was too young blood and the idea of
dying in a video game is far beyond that
of a seven-year-old
and that now it's just you died oh yeah
on the screen yeah you remember that hey
you died everybody died at the same spot
when they turned that corner and that
zombie turned around and looked at you
first time got a backup you're like oh
my god
dude what's funny I remember kid smooth
he had a bet with Bond on weapon wheels
and they said he couldn't beat the game
and kids move bought the legendary
edition that came with infinity infinity
ammo
shooting uh and bond is in the chat you
cheated nah dude I just used what the
game gang
stipulation stipulations no no so all
the Rands out real quick I never asked
because I know you're a horror guy any
Silent Hill at all for you oh man and I
got a story about Silent Hill
let's get it so I never played one my
first Silent Hill ever was two and I'm
gonna date myself and you guys are all
gonna relate so I went to Blockbuster
with my dad
you're still younger than us
let's go let's go we remember when
Blockbuster was getting built
what did you when it first drop
guys outside thanks talk to him I was a
pretty non-biased gamer in my younger
years and we I saw Silent Hill and I had
been exposed to Resident Evil
um so I was like all right let's check
out let's check out Silent Hill I don't
know this looks spooky it was downhill
too which is arguably one of the
favorites of all time right of the south
series and uh we we go home and I I put
it in I start playing and I walk out of
the bathroom and in the smokiness where
my car is parked and I was like oh I
can't get in this carts and it's very
eerie eerie music I start walking down
the street and I see the first thing the
little Wiggly and it's just doing this
I shut it off and I go upstairs and I
was like can we go back and get a
different game
oh his little heart couldn't take it
he's a little guy oh God
that's what he needed Game Pass
Ed it
I got Power Rangers instead I always see
those memes where it says go left for
Silent Hill universe and go right for uh
Resident Evil Universe I'm going right
every time yeah absolutely
I'll fight all that yeah I'm not dealing
with the stuff because at least in right
things semi makes sense it's like you're
not feeling with it with the mist and
the Eerie atmosphere the dark you know
what's it on what's his name
no I just say at least if you go right
in the Resident Evil Universe you are in
like a semi-set of reality if you go
left anything can kill you for that
matter mental torture man that's crazy
even when you run into people in Silent
Hill they're so freaking weird yeah like
you're Fury too because they're dead and
they don't even know it and you're dead
and you're like you you operate on the
premise that you're still alive but
you're not yeah yeah that's the thing
it's a dope story yeah it's just what it
is a solid hell is just how it the
atmosphere makes you uncomfortable yeah
just the atmosphere in general so and
two specifically is story-wise that Hill
does suspense perfectly yeah absolutely
now absolutely you want a horror and all
that so you again went through PS to get
all the consoles um there was a question
I have for you as far as um Nintendo on
consoles and stuff like that any
standout Nintendo consoles do your
journey particularly so like I never got
crazy into anything that was Nintendo
exclusive I played everything okay with
the exception of one game which I'll get
into in a moment
and uh but like as far as like serieses
or genres like I love I love Donkey Kong
like that was great yeah
um but you know what's funny is that
even in in my 64 and and 64 days I was
still playing Shooters you know I was
playing GoldenEye I was playing uh
Perfect Dark I was playing
turoks
64.
it's evil baby
um but yeah nothing really I'm a die
hard anything Nintendo but I've always
I've always respected Nintendo's game
they are very Innovative they do crazy
things and they sometimes succeed and
then there's the Wii U
because everybody thought that thing was
just like a tablet tablet for your Wii
yeah he really didn't understand exactly
what they were taught on that one I left
that one but um
so we can move on just a little bit so
again you got all the the systems you're
engrossed into gaming but I want to
transition as far as content creation
and just like kind of like what inspired
you to kind of start that Journey where
it's like I want to make content about
video games
so I it's funny every time I do a little
I do a little self-reflection which is
always good for any Creator or anyone
and anything you do right I like to look
back and I remember
um when I was in high school and I it's
funny because I'm trying to remember how
I even did these things because uh
technology was so different when I was
in high school right like nobody had
like laptops playing around I don't even
think there was laptops when I was in
high school maybe there was but either
way
um I anytime there was a video project
for class I was always like super
excited I don't know why I was like
super excited I guess it was because I
got to use parents expensive video
camera right
and we'd do stupid stuff like who
remembers MTV when they would do cribs
yeah yeah or cribs or uh or the MTV show
where you would have to like pick
someone to date based off of what their
room looked like room Raiders or
something yo
so we did we did an episode of room
Raiders and I was the camera guy but I
was also directing I was like you know
what we should do is we should take our
friend who's really awkward just have
him like lurking around every corner you
know
and we did every single scene you could
see him somewhere just peering out
somewhere
a post-room interview where they're
sitting in a car they're being like oh
this room was this and that we'd have
them like in the back window like you
could be like like a really creepy
where's wall though like
and and then at the end of the whole
thing like she ended up picking the guy
that was being a creeper the whole time
and that was wow that's right
and uh so yeah I was always like super
excited about that and then it got to
the point where I'd done so many
projects one of my teachers even wrote
in my yearbook they were like hey Todd
great year let me know when you're a
famous movie director and it's so funny
reflecting on that moment that a teacher
actually acknowledged that something
that I was passionate about
and it's funny because like that
happened and that's one of the things I
reflect on a lot and it's one of the
things I I Love Actually I haven't I
haven't deemed dm'd him yet I was going
to DM hey look what I got going on you
know all right check out Danny's uh
um I've always been messing around
creating videos my first Montage I made
a Gears of War montages when that came
out that was my game man like I jammed
with Gears of War and I don't I and I
always try to remember how did I even
get gameplay from my Xbox to the
computer and what was I editing yeah I
don't have those answers in my head back
then that was an adventure just to get
that going yes continue I think I used
like a flash drive and all I did was
like take clips of me playing and
transfer it over that's the only thing I
can think of
um Gears of War montages uh and then I'm
huge into fitness working out all that
lifestyle so I've made my fair share of
Fitness yeah well plate carrier please
say that louder to Cog
please say that louder to Cog please uh
told him a million times
who helped as well
every week There's No Inspirations you
know what's dope when I got a chance to
see both of y'all interact live
and you know y'all share the same energy
right so I just accept it that's what I
talk about when we DM to each other on
Twitter and I was like dude I love your
guys I've been watching your guys
podcast I was like I love you guys
energy it's awesome love much love much
love and likewise like I said we we
cross paths and I was just like yo I
love what he's doing and you know be
talking about your journey with content
creation and video games but some of the
stuff that I saw actually was you
reviewing plate carrier vest which I
thought was dope like you was literally
like yo this is fast you know if you
want to get your workout how to add that
extra layer to it and the way you was
breaking it down so I was like son was
doing
Fitness stuff too in a way so I wanted
to like say like I guess I want to ask
you
was it gaming first or was it the other
things first and then it kind of
transitioned the game because you always
had that passion for gaming
um haphazard is the only way to describe
okay
got it because I love doing everything
like if I really wanted to I could even
make a YouTube channel about how to edit
video and how to do like how to create
and like how I'm gonna have to hire you
for that because
I need to know how to do I'm terrible
I'm terrible I've hired one editor ever
and uh he was a great guy but like he
couldn't emulate exactly what I wanted
to do
and I and you know that's the problem
with you create and you get really good
at it
yeah it's like you're just now you're
just more nitpicky unfortunately so I'm
I guess I'm stuck forever so you remind
me of addicted that way because attic is
very particular with his vision and when
he knows what he wants sometimes if he's
if he's not paired with the correct
editor or artist whatever he just rather
do it himself then because he's just
like you know I'll do it kind of thing
because you know I think creatives like
you guys you guys visualize it and know
what it should look like and that that's
a talent that's a strength
it really started gaming because I did
montages I made several I wish I could
find them I don't know what channel I
was on or anything like that they might
have deleted them because I did it all
to kill switch engage music because it's
like one of my favorite bands it might
have like just removed the channel
because of so much copyright then
um then I made Fitness montages probably
through the 2012s and 2014 2015 stuff
like that editing videos never never
knew about camera stabilization so
they're very shaky
they look like The Blair Witch
and I started getting into plate carrier
training and I was like you know what I
should do is like just start my YouTube
channel and review random things that I
have around the house and like I even
mentioned it in a few videos like no
bull shoes
um whether or not they're good or not uh
Bridge wallet uh I bought one of those
and I was like this thing's pretty cool
here on the level block and then plate
carriers because why not you know and I
mean it is your staple I mean it's part
of the owl yeah that's part of it thank
you yeah yeah this video has almost got
me monetized because a lot of people uh
like they want to know about gear you
know and I had one plate carrier which
is the Condor by uh Rogue Fitness and
that was the first video I did and
that's that's sitting at about 20 000
views and then the one about the cry
Tech Precision the AR 500 and the and
then the Rogue one again
um that video I actually was really
proud of because it's definitely an
outlier on my channel as far as
um the quality of the video yeah that's
all non-script written either like
yeah that's before I even learned to
write yeah yeah you know I can respect
the fellow freestyler you know I can
respect it did you did you see when he
just got into his so his moment right
there so yeah no because you know what I
got it you gotta go back and look at the
videos
I will never give myself a lot of
flowers I'm very humble but one thing I
I respect is someone who can kind of
freestyle it off the the top spontaneous
that's an art like a lot of people a lot
of times you don't say like especially
like interviewing and stuff like that
like I just you could just go you know
what I'm saying that obviously with a
show and stuff some things are obviously
scripted and stuff like that but I
respect that he said that because I know
how difficult that is a lot of people
cannot do that and to sit there turn the
camera on and just talk about blah blah
blah and it comes from the heart and to
be entertaining and you're not having to
you know edit as much that's a scale man
so you know I gotta I gotta respect the
fellow freestylers outside you know what
I mean like that's that's dope man real
quick I want to give you give you a
quick shout out on from the homegirl
Bridget Summer she said we love Todd he
is an amazing Creator he has an amazing
personality about him that shows when he
streams so you gotta fan up in there
shout out to Lady Bridgette summer
Cinema it's one of my uh fox den members
right there they're an avid watcher on
the twitch Channel and always there with
good spirits dull so absolutely glad
she's still in here hanging out I still
yeah because we out of pocket sorry for
any bad impressions
but uh
oh yeah um so to any like inspired
creators also that might be in the chat
because you know some of the biggest
viewers out there are other creators or
people that want to create too you know
absolutely and like one of the biggest
things like yeah it's also it's cool to
write scripts because now you know
exactly what you want to talk about when
you're on doing whatever right you're
shooting your Tick Tock you're shooting
your YouTube video whatever it may be
but the biggest thing I've told people
to help make them make their content
better is stop looking at your camera
like it's a camera and talk to it like
it's another human being
that's the best way like because yeah
just think how nice this conversation is
between me and you guys right now this
is exactly how I talk to my camera let's
go little town hey I'm solo agrees he
says facts no doubt love I love it love
the energy so real quick I gotta ask you
know as a content creator I would always
consider magic moments moments where
either as a content creator you reflect
that you look back and say okay this was
a breakthrough for me for my Channel or
my content or just like when you feel
you were in pocket and everything is
kind of working for you so what what
moment when you consider or moments do
you consider for yourself so far on your
journey that are magic for you
so yeah like I guess I guess I started
you know Tick Tock around everyone else
did you know like the um and then Tick
Tock is definitely my moment like it's
definitely and I've had moments within
it now that have also done that as well
and um one of the biggest ones was like
I have a whole Tick Tock that's like my
private one where it's not private but
like you could still see it but I have
like all the stuff where I was doing the
lip syncing where I was doing like skits
I was doing whatever because like
honestly dude I'll be for real one of my
lifetime goals is to be in a video game
and be an actor because I think I have
exactly what it takes to do that kind of
stuff I agree it exudes it exudes that's
for sure
I'm passionate man I love it I love
doing the lip syncing and the facial
expressions and like just making it feel
like a moment right
um so I have a whole channel of me
making that type of content for probably
close to two years and uh and then I
started a second Channel where I was
doing gaming clips and stuff like that I
ended up deleting all of them because I
had that for about half the time I had
the other one so about a year ended up
deleting all I was like you know what
I'm gonna do something wildly different
I'm just gonna do because I've seen
people who do gaming news right
um but the thing is is those people that
were doing gaming news were only talking
about Call of Duty they were talking
about fortnite Apex that is it that's
why I was like
I see an end here and the first video I
did was talking about Tiny Tina's
wonderlands because I'm a Borderland fan
in that video blew up and then I had a
second video talking about new world and
that video didn't blow up but it did
well
but like 7 000 is still really good in
the grand scheme of this right you got
people out there getting 20 views right
so yeah in comparison you know it's
gonna sound biased because like I had
one blow up and then that one didn't so
that one didn't in my eyes and I started
covering like I would go like skin packs
were leaking for like Call of Duty so I
was like oh here's everything you get in
this skin pack and then that was I just
show them the skin pack and work on my
editing and then you know Resident Evil
news like just anything you know Dead
Space started coming out started talking
about dead space like yeah so I just
talked about all these games that just
don't get the light and I know that that
keeps My Views down because they're all
Niche communities but at the same time
those communities would like to probably
hear this news you know
so yeah starting that page getting that
first hundred thousand view video was
like did I just do something right the
first one was the first one that hit
uh that was that first video that was
that first one that very first one okay
and then it hooks yeah it's like a drill
yeah because you get addicted to that
level of success and you strive harder
my question is you said that um you knew
and it was a conscious thought that you
uh attacking these
these uh Niche games knew that you were
going to get us uh smaller Returns on
investment but you felt that investment
in that ecosystem was warranted because
those people needed to be heard did you
say that because you like that game as
well and people weren't talking about it
and you wanted to be that voice that's
exactly correct yep yep because I was
like I was like I I don't I scroll on
Tick Tock for hours like oh we all do
yeah and I'd never see anything about
games that I was interested in I mean I
guess I was playing Call of Duty but I
wasn't like searching for that news
constantly you know so like it felt nice
and it felt right to be talking about
something one I'm passionate about
because I'm not going to talk about
something I'm not passionate about
that's silly because now I'm just not
I'm selling out yeah all right you're
doing it for the back do it for the best
there are some of those situations where
like you know like people call it like
you know you do an ad right and people
like oh you sold out blah blah blah and
I was like well at the same time you're
not paying my bills man
I made 100 videos in the past few months
no money I didn't want to add you know
so it's like I look I look at those like
look it's like advertising on anything
they paid me to tell you the product you
don't have to go buy the product yeah
a question I just I think it's funny
that in the sense that you know the
grind of content creation you know night
in Night Out Blood Sweat and Tears you
know you come in you're showing up and
you're not getting paid and then the
first time there's anything offered to
compensate you I find it funny that the
audience gets mad that anyways yeah
we'll take that and then it's just funny
to me like it's just like because I
would just be honest like I feel like
there's a lot of fraudulent Behavior if
people were in that same situation that
they they go sit there and say no I
worked hard for all these years and I'm
not going to do an ad spot or something
like that that to me it's recognition of
your grind and what's going on in your
audience it's up to you to choose if
that product or thing you talk about is
reflective of your brand but I always
find it funny when I see the show stuff
that I'm like I did the same people I'll
catch doing an ad read later on when
they blow up and I sit there and I'm
going I remember
you you was definitely talking about so
sorry
the thing people don't realize is in
order to grow to a mass degree you need
money and influence absolutely um it's
like anything else do you think that
like all these Brands Coca-Cola do you
think manscape goes out there and they
do massive amounts of like marketing and
putting money in creators Pockets to get
their name out they do that and that's
what we're trying to do we try to get
the money to do that even though it's
funny no addict the fake moral compass
some people try to exude I just think
it's Hilary knew how hard it was to get
a sponsor off you would not say a word
like it is hard as hell we've been doing
this since 2017 and we just recently
started getting involved we've got to
look at if they look at the product you
can say off the product alone they might
like the product right but they don't
look at your product they go straight to
how many uh yeah all the subs that you
have Subs numbers all that absolutely
absolutely no it's just important I love
that Todd you know brought that up
because it's again that grind is his
consistent grind I'm seeing I'm seeing
the comments in the chat form and it's
just shot of Aiden been watching Todd's
tick tocks for a long time he just
started watching the streams his
passionate is contagious it made me
start pursuing my active and creative
Journey again he was like lfg fox den
talk to him about the fox then talk to
him appreciate you Aiden
no doubt yeah I got my man John Wolf
gave you a follow-on twitch that's what
it's up that's what's up that's what's
up so I did so basically that was the
Breakthrough and then you feel like you
started to sit in jobs more than editing
because one thing I really like about
your content is like it's very
insightful and especially when you're
giving information even when you're like
breaking okay this is the new update or
did you hear the characters or here's
what's about to happen in this
particular information bit is really
well done so you feel like when you feel
you got into your pocket like editing
and content-wise we're starting to flow
even more natural for you uh well I mean
the flow is really nice because I don't
know if there's any editors in chat
right now but like just learning
shortcuts short keys and stuff like that
learning tips like tips and tricks like
I have a template an image of like what
my stuff looks like I drop it in and I
overlay my video and video gameplay that
makes it faster I have fonts already
pre-made that I made myself okay like
just stuff like that to where like it
just saves me time and I swear I can
usually bust out a video and yeah and I
do I work hard on my videos like a lot
of people like oh you you need to be
able to make one in 30 minutes and I'm
like I'm gonna give them an hour long
video and I'm gonna make it look really
nice
like that little extra crisp like dude
there isn't a thing I put on there don't
have a drop shadow on it to lift it up a
little bit is he talking right now is he
preaching
let them cook let them cook let them
cook
and I said that to you the other day too
when I made that thumbnail yes for us
yes I was like I'm gonna make this thing
look a little tasty
but you were like I love hearing that
are you self-taught and self-trained oh
good question
everything is self-taught I've I've
learned everything I've learned how to
do I've literally looked up on YouTube
I've read I've watched tutorials so I
guess I'm not self-taught I guess people
have showed me on on YouTube that's
motivation that's something totally
different like your motivation allowed
you to go seek that out but you taught
yourself see some people can watch a
video and can't retain this stuff
because they don't have comprehension
skills but you have the motivation
comprehensive skills institutiveness to
stick with whatever you want and you're
just like a real go-getter so my biggest
question was like did you go to school
for this because a lot of editors go to
school for this stuff and the way your
your tick tocks and stuff are is like
I'm I thought you was
his girl and she had her like
try to identify what game characters
were oh man that was a good video yo
that was wow funny and the way he broke
it down and that you had the NFL sir
and then I was like yo just the way it
just still small little subtle details
I'm like damn he put so much time into
that people don't realize how much that
would continue though now my favorite of
that video specifically is when uh what
what she called uh Commander Shepard
Trump Joe we're talking about his bulge
I was like
wow yeah
so it's a little you're out here those
are videos that are fun to make too man
like those are those are just good like
I'm laughing watching them and oh man
that's the biggest thing is like that
whole first Tick Tock I made with my
like why was lip syncing and making
jokes and all that stuff like that I'm
laughing I'm making myself happy because
I'm like that's like you I hope that
anybody who's creating content is happy
right you're just not grinding with your
eyes burning and drinking four million
killer programs of caffeine or whatever
thanks it's like miserable right like I
am like when I post a video I am like I
hope that does good because I'm really
proud of it same thing is it's the same
like even though I'm not in the on the
video space for me it's like the prep
for the show so it's like when I I
remember there was a period at the
beginning I was like damn I used to
speak the attic should I continue to do
the intros and Kyle he's like nah God
you gotta do that and then it just got
more Dimension even more in my
personality and then I'm doing it and
laughing I'm like yeah yeah
they're gonna get it today again if you
you gotta enjoy what you're doing if you
don't have that passion for what you're
doing is going to feel like work then
you're going to end up being resentful
towards and you don't want to be in that
space right so it's like it's a very
important thing I want to get added he
seems like he had bars about the editing
stuff I didn't want to uh interact I
want to Circle back to King real fast
about going to school and stuff like
that I went to college
um that's the whole reason I actually
joined the military was to get school
paid for
um I started off in finance dude and I
was like that's my major is finance and
after a while and I'm a very aware human
being and like I'm sitting there in
classes I'm 20 25 I'm 26 years old and
these teachers are like they're like oh
if you missed three classes we're gonna
start docking your grade and I'm like
because I'm talking everyone like
they're kids right I'm like I'm 26.
you're not docking my grade for crap and
I'm paying you you're my you are my
employee yeah exactly and I had I walked
it all the way up to the dean man I was
like you aren't back in my grade for
anything I'm paying for these classes
because they she literally said she was
like your parents pay good money to put
you guys through college blah blah and
for crap you are and I am yeah like and
after a while like I was like man
college is such a business and I I'm
gonna be honestly I'm not trying to be a
bad influence I know where you're going
I dropped out man I said no more it
wasn't why that's why all this stuff is
self-taught because there's no greater
time in the world to teach yourself
anything because someone has made a
YouTube video about what you want to
learn Yes except for maybe Astro nope
there's definitely astross
definitely out there so it's like I If
you're a go-getter and like you said I
mean you're calling me go get her I'm
not saying it I'm not applicable
um you know I'm so humble
[Laughter]
if you got the drive to learn something
you can go learn it and that's you know
one of my biggest shout out to freaking
Harris Heller you know that's the guy
that got me into content creation you
might have heard his name before but it
was the stream doctor he taught everyone
how to stream audio video editing all
kinds of stuff I used to watch his
videos I would drive long distance
because my girlfriend lived two hours
away I just throw his YouTube videos up
and just listen it motivated me to get
back into really creating and then then
here I am
no doubt solve I want to make sure you
have bars that see your ass up to say
just want to make sure yeah yeah I was
going to say that like
it's crazy how much Tick Tock has
influenced the entire content creation
you're seeing people like Drop intros
because they feel like you know they
gotta have a better a better you know
come out because like they call oh we've
already forgot what it is you're um your
opening statement what are they called
The Hook yeah so they call that the hook
it's pretty much like because people
have to grab you from the start when it
comes to shorts they're starting to take
that concept and put it over to actual
video making like long form content and
it's just crazy how like
that app
yeah just completely changed how all
content is made yeah I mean you've seen
YouTube now adopt shorts right you've
seen you know the influences is insane
and then again I'm being you know older
gamer resisted you know stuck in my
stubborn ways and I remember the
sentences in the attics like yo bro you
got to see what's going on The Tick Tock
and I seen it and I'm like it's short
content but it's just so well edited and
done and then what happens is that Loop
if you really like something and then
you just Loop it just Loops it Loop and
sometimes you'll find yourself stuck in
the loop if you really enjoy something
so I do see it I do see the influence I
I do I'm sorry I'm gonna get your balls
off you good or another question yeah I
know the school stuff is is really it
resonates with me because I for me and
let's be clear I I've squandered plenty
of opportunities
let's be perfectly clear
but what you do realize is that it is a
business and and they're so caught up in
sort of sort of maintaining the order of
it that they kind of forget that you
know yeah some people's parents are
paying but if you're an older person in
school then you're probably paying for
it yourself and at that point like you
have the realities of life to balance
and when you tell me that I have a
full-time job and if I don't you know if
I'm not in class it's one thing if you
tell me hey this thing has to be turned
in a certain time yeah and you know hey
I get that now if you tell me I'm not in
the seat for whatever the reason may be
I'm gonna fail even if I turn in an A
plus paper whatever the case may be then
I have a problem
and I there was a lot of that same
pushback for me and for me it's very
true though when you look at the world
out there
um there's so much more that you get out
of experience and I'm not trying to
again knock anybody the Lord say don't
go to college
yeah is excellent the thing about it is
there's always there's a trade-off and a
balance there's a trade-off and a
balance because again I work in a
hospital I I work for them in a medical
school actually and there's so many
doctors there the ones that come from
money already are cool right if you're
not coming from money and you totally
you're you're you're the rest of your
life is spent paying more money back
yeah pay it back yeah
so it's you know there's balance there
yeah
that means if you actually get a job out
of your life
the thing I feel like I feel like
schools is definitely an Avenue but
people need to be realistic on what you
really should be going to school for
like people sit there I remember growing
up people was like oh you know what do
you what are you interested in that's
what you go to school for no what could
you handle and enjoy doing and make
money that's what you should go to
school for well and it's that's a
different type of balance than that um
you know shout out to Todd for
knowing recognizing I'm not going to use
my money I'm using a military money
right yeah
exactly the way around it yeah because
the thing about it is like it I tell you
man like for as somebody who busts his
tail you know five days a week working
hard and I'm like okay and the thing
about it is I have to do that because of
the things that I've squandered in the
past right and I accept that I realized
that shame the devil so you know so what
can I do I do IOP right IOP and maybe
dip my toe a little bit into it and
hopefully you know I can balance the
realities of my responsibilities which
still kind of following dreams and and
still doing both of them but yeah man
like if you're young enough and you
understand that hey this isn't for me I
can find another way you're probably
right you're probably right if you look
around
room
and everybody's getting paid but you
um
it is what it is now I'm glad you
mentioned the uh that Todd as far as
also you know the the military aspect
because I want to transition to that
like one thing I really respect is
obviously you know your service right
you know you don't kind of shy away from
that Air Force National Guard I believe
and um correct you know I I think I
guess my question for you is how is that
experience influenced you as a content
creator in general
uh well it's funny too I have a couple
things that really stood out because I
remember I have teachers that didn't
like me and were instructors they're
instructors and instructors that love me
okay okay that's funny because I
remember uh so the journey into the
military was obviously I didn't want to
pay for school myself and I was working
at Panera Bread at the time it was
2010-ish
sandwiches love sandwiches right oh yeah
which is lit continue I didn't have a
girlfriend I had to make my own sandwich
[Music]
but uh so I uh I'm Mosey on because my
brother actually is the reason I end up
joined the military he's uh he was 18 uh
he's younger than me just graduated he's
like I'm doing the Marine Corps I'm
going and I was like dang my little
brother about to show me up because I
ain't done crap in like five years
um I had a going to see his recruiter
with him and I thought Marine sounded
cool and stuff like that but I did hear
a famous quote that there's no need for
a scout sniper in the neighborhood watch
which means like a lot of those jobs
aren't going to translate once you
separate and I was like oh yeah that's
[Music]
I was older and I knew that the Air
Force is way more career oriented
because my older brother had been here
of course yeah
I'm sorry your father my father was an
Air Force yeah that's what's up respect
um so I I was just Mosey and I one day
and I I noticed an Air National Guard
recruiting office and I just mosed it in
there and they were like oh we need man
Mechanics for aircraft do you want to be
a mechanic and I was like that sounds
way cooler than making sandwiches for
eight dollars now I respect that I
respect that oh yeah I ended up going
through the whole process getting to
joining up and uh at tech school I was
uh had one teacher that was like you
talk too much and you're gonna make all
your ncos non-commissioned officers all
your bosses you're gonna make them mad
so shut the f up
a lot of questions that you was asking
or no I was a pleasure I was a joke
he said Air Force brats stand up okay
continue
so so I went from that class and then
immediately you graduate like sections
basically so like that section was done
that was the one where they're like this
is a hammer this is a wrench like that
then I immediately go into hydraulics
it's like sped up and that teacher was a
civilian prior service air force uh
retired and when I graduated finally she
was like you have one of the best sense
of humors I've ever experienced in a
classroom and on a flight line make sure
you keep that energy because the people
around you doing the job they do is hard
and they're going to need that relief
every once in a while and I was like I
don't know what they want from me do you
want me to shut up or do you want me to
be funny I don't know what to do
that was that was her giving you that
encouragement because you probably
realized that other people was talking
like he needs to shut up and she's like
no I needed that laugh this morning
because I wanted to choke somebody
[Laughter]
it shows there's so many different types
of people out there you know no no
absolutely absolutely and again it goes
to show your personality comes out you
know as a result of that content is
super dope loving what you're doing out
here in the realm silly question are you
predisposed to Microsoft flight
simulator as a result
[Laughter]
[Applause]
simulator when you see it I I've never
played a flight simulator now okay okay
shout out to you
I don't want to see another plane I only
take place you know the Maverick type of
Maverick expansion designer didn't want
to know if he had a disposition
he said absolutely no sir
I thought he had to need the Need for
Speed but anyways
and I'm saying there we go see bro
Microsoft get on look man there we go
this is the DLC right yeah we've got a
little bit like a Top Gun character yeah
I'd be pretty proud but also confused
I'm like wrong why can't I be in another
game why can't I be in Gears of War 6
you know true
he like God don't mess with my bag I
want gears sir I want gears he's like
leave that flies
maybe Todd Cruz is Johnny Cage
[Applause]
and say hey have you ever taken apart a
plane
oh don't be doing that Reno 9-1-1 we're
not doing that we're not doing that they
said they said uh was it they said David
Arquette is looking kind of brolic these
days
yeah David Arquette
Todd Maverick let me let me round out
one more thing about the military though
because I will say that the whole reason
I financially can afford to do this dumb
stuff back here that you see is because
of the military like uh they have they
put the bread on the table and you know
it I don't I would not there are times
and I'm
there are times where I'm like I would
not be doing this at all if it wasn't
for the job that I have so love love not
absolutes a little stool Jersey's got 14
years in the Air Force best thing he
ever did 11 out of ten chat giving you a
lot of love and solutions that's what
I'm talking about brother no doubt I'm
gonna send my son your
um your your Twitter link because uh he
doesn't want to listen to his
grandfather he doesn't want to listen to
me and I want him to go to the Air Force
ASAP
it's real man like we got it's nice over
here we got the nice stuff we got indoor
plumbing
once you start seeing the world you're
like okay
got it good over here oh big bad oh it's
a lot of Air Force in the big about 10
years in the Air Force okay yeah that's
why they respected that hold the line
that makes sense I respect a lot of
people coming forward that's what's up
man no you guys got a strong chat that's
what I'm saying
we got one of the best communities I'm
super super humble now I'm surprised we
got 500 and some change on Mother's Day
yeah on Mother's Day everybody
yeah people are throwing it up pragmatic
Eagle Army 21 years states of USMC
Daniel six yeah yo they throwing it up
right now
everybody's putting their resume up a
lot of that that's what I'm talking
about time for Toonami eight okay but
recall okay all right I see what it is
no doubt so look we got to ask you the
question that we ask all the guests in
the realm all right no pressure but you
know top five video games or franchises
of all time for Lord time top five video
games you want to start with five yeah
any and it doesn't have to be a
particular order and it could be again
this individual game or the franchises
you know whatever however you want to
attack it uh I'm sure this answer will
probably change every time because I am
a person who enjoys so many types of
games right
I think for the number one I got to give
a slot to for sure is definitely Metal
Gear Solid two
that is a game that I have put
and umpteen about million of hours into
right like it's I could have gotten a
college degree in the time I've played
Metal Gear solitude
um so Metal Gear Solid 2 is definitely a
good one I'm excited to hear about you
know possible Metal Gear Solid 3 getting
remade even though I thought that was a
weaker game in the series but Snake
Eater Snake Eater it was good but I
thought
two was definitely yeah remade I think
it just has the greatest song in Metal
Gear History yeah
two was like his Pinnacle that's when he
he reached that status
we got Metal Gear I'll throw in Resident
Evil 2 is probably a game that will
always live an end for me for me infamy
um because I love the fact that they had
so many like Easter eggs like unlocking
hunk yes yes yeah the way they fleshed
out be
these scenarios to get the full story
and dynamically change them up that's
like that's really curving you know like
people just play a video game start to
finish and then it's over but they're
like hey guess what here's two other
scenarios yes
that's crazy what is it uh we call them
Tyrant that's still one of the greatest
Mr Mr X Mr X at the time yes but
um yeah like the thing too is like they
they created the software to have him
chase you yes
that's gnarly yeah like when when he
went from I thought he couldn't go from
the one section you know I thought he
was Dumb and then he went to the other
section he was coming through I said oh
no he really coming through y'all when
he burst through the wall yeah I said
because the gay I was like yo you're not
supposed to do it you're not going by
the laws of the game it did it's nothing
more fearful than this like indomitable
like invulnerable thing that you really
can't stop that's hunting you down it
just added a level of tension for like
you got relieved when you made it to the
save room okay
the music okay yes yes typewriter please
save me typewriter yes absolutely so we
got Resident Evil too okay what else we
got I'm gonna throw Gears of War in
there as far as a favorite uh
multiplayer slash unique story I
remember following that when Game
Informer was covering it I used to have
the original Game Informer where they
talked about the game and they were
going through like what to expect and
then they changed it afterwards I wish I
could find it because I'd love to frame
it and have it up because like the
artwork looked different the enemies
look different the Krill were going to
be way more prominent like this game
looks so crazy and then they then they
dialed the curl down yeah they got the
curl down yeah yeah but I was like that
Gears of War man I oh boy I played that
I was top 300 in the world war zone
the one where it's just it's all about
kills and KD and stuff like that I had
like a three two one KD like I was up
there that's and that after like a
hundred then you're in the hackers
let me ask you a question where were you
when you first saw the commercial for
Gears of War yeah oh she was probably in
my my basement at home and as a 18 year
old who had a part-time job but I
remember Mad World actually I think I
just uh I just posted a uh on Instagram
talking about my swag back here I got a
statue of Marcus Phoenix uh from three
like that playing Mad World do it on
Instagram wait you got that autograph
uh yeah yeah
I'll check it out I didn't know that
yeah you got the music going too I just
played the music just overlaid it with
the music but I was just you know
showing regular gamer swag because I
have an Isaac Clark helmet back there
it's illuminated actually yes that's it
salute I love it I love all that stuff
everything
absolutely oh man I I there's if there's
something iconic and that's the cool
thing about being a gamer right so you
see anything that you love you could be
uh you can collect memorabilia of it and
just kind of surrounded by the things
that kind of shape your gamer
personality you know actual factual um
yeah so Gears of War is a franchises in
general I five and four and five are and
for me they're they're Gears of War
games but not really I need to go back
to being grungy right so you like the
Cliffy B join we had Cliffy on we had
Cliffy on and he cut them back into it
yeah yeah yeah he said uh you know it's
cool with Phil so maybe you know
Consulting role or something for the
next one so we see so we got two more
okay uh number two gosh let's make us
I know what number one is I don't want
to say it yet though number two I'm
probably gonna slot in the Devil May Cry
series oh I didn't see this cover I was
uh am still huge Devil May Cry fan I've
Loved literally all of them
actually you know what's funny is
everyone hated too I think it's voted
like the worst game in the world next to
that EP game that didn't have an exit
I remember playing DMC too and like I
remember all the problems that it had
and I was like this game is so cool man
dmc2 or Devil May Cry to because yeah we
may cry too Devil May Cry too yeah all
right okay so there was the Devil May
Cry one two and three and then he's
getting into DMC where they are young
yeah I also I like that game everyone
said they didn't like him young I still
liked it okay
I affectionately call him crackhead
Dante
looked like he was smoking
dude that was the first time I think I
could remember if you could play as
Virgil and Devil May Cry 3 but I know
you could play as Virgil and DMC and
that was really sweet yeah I really I
really liked the Devil May Cry franchise
I kind of like it's not bigger I dropped
the the fifth one and I feel like that
was the better one oh man I don't know I
was phenomenal I don't know why I just I
personally feel like they were really
push you for microtransactions like when
it first came out
it just like there was so there were
certain things I was doing that I was
like jeez man
my son's name is Dante because of uh
Devil May Cry fire fire no doubt
it feels egregious to not put Resident
Evil 4 on the list so you could use
Resident Evil as a franchise yeah I'll
put Resident Evil as a franchise he was
just one that really stuck out with me
four is definitely on there um so yeah
I'll put Resident Evil as the franchise
back a little earlier
um and then my number one game all the
time I always answer this question the
same one every single time is Final
Fantasy 10 because
wow because this is a game that I
actively I was open-minded I said
earlier when I go to Blockbuster and
rent my games right well Blockbuster was
still around when Final Fantasy 10 came
out okay and I I'd seen it on the
shelves forever and I just I just saw
the cover art and I was like that looks
stupid
I ain't messing with that that looks
stupid wow well if you remember you know
tennis is uh uh it's so wild it is the
yellow with the thing yeah the pants
that had like mesh you know yes and I
also I'm I don't know why I'm so literal
but I was like Final Fantasy 10 I was
like how's it the Final Fantasy if this
is the temperature
you was coming here
didn't they get that style after the
bouncer and I think they did the bouncer
first and then they did 10 after that
yeah yeah that's right 10 was the first
uh PS2 RPG right yeah it was it was the
bouncer was like a launch game yeah The
Bouncer and they used that style people
loved that art style and that's when 10
came out and Titus was wearing those
clothes
I guess we're wrong it's not that it's
Titus
he's the tightest guy around us
oh man
there we go there we go more accurate
than Titus
so you get this game home after he was
slandering it at the Blockbuster by the
color I ended up I ended up picking this
game up and I was infatuated with it I
couldn't put it down right I got a funny
story inside of the story so I'm gonna
say that I I had my dad rent it for me
on three separate weeks I we and then
finally he just showed up where they
bought it
it was like I'm tired of buying this
renting this game for you yep because
I'm just buying it for you so I was like
all right dope I put I've I've probably
made about three or four files over it I
had a file dedicated to just playing
Blitzball I was recruiting people from
other other
and uh I have I have easily over a
thousand hours into that game I've done
everything you could possibly do and
actually I had someone from my chat
recently challenged that he was going to
show me something I've never seen in the
game and I was like good luck I'll take
that bet
um
so funny funny story about playing that
game though is I am not a person that
reads I hate reading which is funny
because I write script I want to hear
how you navigate this part they're good
I want to hit this part right here this
part will be interesting yes they said
so listen I want you to take apart this
plane he said man I don't need to read
that
because it gives me it gives me huge
add-on to the instructions Vibes I want
to hear where we going with this Lord
Todd but continue when I put together
exactly
they comes up with all the tutorials as
they come up because the first you know
some odd minutes of the game is all like
learn how to play right well we get to
the part we're on the ship with Riku and
explains the spear grid and I was
looking at this big thing that obviously
I've never played at RPG before ever oh
it's got this big thing and I was like
what is this and it zoomed out to as big
as it gets and I remember that part I
was like what is this oh wait whatever
[__]
yeah you're good and uh and I get so so
far into this game right I'm at the par
you guys have you guys all played Final
Fantasy 10. yeah yeah remember we part
we were fighting Riku and the makina in
the in the lake yeah yeah and so you
don't realize it's her until after you
beat her well I got to that part and I
couldn't beat her and keep one shot I
didn't slot none of your stuff I never
used a single level
was this the was this the remaster or
the original this is on PS2 yeah what's
funny is it in the in the remasters
because in in the original ones they was
pretty much like they made you go that
everyone had a certain path and they
kind of made you do that well in the re
uh because what I used to do is I used
to take Titus to Oren's path because it
would make him stronger yeah and then I
would go through Titus as fast but in
the remake they're like yo do you know
how to use do you know this feel great
and I'm like yeah he's like we're just
gonna open all of the slots so if you
don't know how to use this fear grid
say it now
for people like me yes but pretty much
like the majority of the map was like
blocked off like one character couldn't
go into another character's uh like like
path because there's like a lot of level
one and two speakers stopping it but if
you do if you say I know I want the
advanced version they get rid of all
those one and twos so you could
literally go anywhere within reason I
remember I used to just have because
when I zoomed out because there's an
achievement to get every single person
unlocking every sphere grid and then I
was I'm gonna get this and then I
started realizing they meant the empty
ones too and I'm like okay I'm not doing
that
I did I completed the sphere grid with
everyone with everyone I went through
every path with everyone damn I filled
every Blank Spot you could fill and
everybody
if they see all my characters did that
if they would just like like like let
you click somewhere on the sphere go
okay you got 99 spots and then you say
you want to go here and say it's like
and this is yes and if they would just
be like do you want to activate your
your uh you know Power Sphere uh
abilities Fair do you just want to
activate them as they go I would have
did it but they're like no you got to
stop here and activate these move over
here stop here and activate these no we
ain't doing nothing
[Music]
my people are already doing 99 000 like
like no if we had there's a yoon is a
mage she's not supposed to do a lot of
physical damage I had her doing 99
999. you know what's a wand even though
it was a Viking Warrior in my
playthrough wow that's crazy that's
great I love the fact that she read the
land and you got to that part though
yeah
yeah and then he had Foster read yeah
you know oh he said I'm I'm gonna get
this on natural Talent I'm all Natty
with this and they got up to her and she
was like yeah you're gonna get in this
book right here and um right here where
you didn't want to read you're gonna
have to read this area
so Final Fantasy 10 wow that's a I think
that's the first that's the first one
first time we had to guess yeah that's
the first time we've seen it yeah it's
the most popular answer what's the most
popular what do you get so many oh my
God
it's usually sometimes we see Mass
Effect on your vest it's Mass Effect so
I was surprised it wasn't though
definitely I mean like I said it's a
hard top five yeah like top five is
probably the hardest answer to give I
would say Final Fantasy 10 is you can
argue I would let people argue that's
the best one they've made like never
I won't let you make that argument
let me address
something good on
[Music]
we see the one that got the most
influence that's what matters that's
what the weather is that going for it
you know what it makes you go go out cop
something it makes you remember it is
that's what I'm talking about that's the
true influence the Final Fantasy game
and it also works as a a hell of a scary
weapon when somebody busts inside your
house you'd be like oh this you picked
the right house
[Applause]
you good
we cooking a beer you shut the door
imagine imagine you like you break into
a house and the door slams behind you
and locks and then there's like two by
fours that go in front of this
you just see someone like in a recliner
that says you picked the wrong
you hear one little kid you hear one
little kid in the background daddy we
got dinner
[Laughter]
these two are messy no I just wanted to
address the alpha alpha uvl in the chat
okay I immediately jumped saying oh it's
not even the Final Fantasy 10 isn't even
the first PS2 RPG or jrpg and I'm like I
didn't say that you know what I meant
the first Final Fantasy RPG on PS2 and
yes it is because dirt the servers came
out in 2006. as opposed to 2001 Final
Fantasy 10 so yeah guess who was online
getting it and guess who wasn't yeah
yeah but again you know it does I know
just listen to the podcast
don't need to sit there with a pen and
paper
frogs off that chicken nah so
I just I just when I see people do that
I just Envision them behind their
computer with like five monitors like 20
tabs on every month but then my thing is
just be right then oh that would be
right
yeah I ain't gonna look it up and still
be wrong anyway shout out to the homie
who gave us two cents but you're gonna
get this work if y'all
happy Mother's day you'll get the Happy
Mother's Day Final Fantasy 10 and then
the final question we usually ask all in
the realm favorite console of all time
and why nowhere I have no idea
this one this one's this is an easy
answer and I feel like there's lots of
different answers out there but the it's
got to be the answer for me has got to
be the answer where I had the most fun
gaming in my entire life and it's going
to be the Xbox 360. wow let's go let's
go let's go no you don't like that
answer yes
yes
Xbox 360 man like the birth of Gears of
War Modern Warfare
um uh Modern Warfare oh there we go we
got the bling out right there it's
coming in the middle yeah
good ring of death
nobody we all battled the red ring of
death all right we had to yeah with a
towel or something and bake it or
something yeah talk about that 360 talk
time talk to him yeah so like I mean
shoot I posted that that Twitter post
the other day about the GamePad where
you could text on your little controller
yup I saw that I saw it it still has it
[__] all my crap that was Twitter
fingers before you had Twitter yeah yeah
yeah and now you can't do nothing on
Twitter
you got that dude the Xbox basically
camera accessory oh yeah Uno after I
like the three did you play after dark
uno no no I like that I like that 360
wireless headset around your ears
that little earpiece guys it looked cool
too I got I got rid of that once once I
saw anus on camera nope oh yeah
I'm like yo I called him on his phone I
said man you ain't even answering my
text what's up I see you saw me you saw
me yo let me in the room it's I I see
you saw me say you saw you
you know when you go in a room and you
see something you don't want to see like
walk in on your parents by mistake oh
um no I don't remember doing a lot of
that I was really playing like a lot of
those AAA games you know like obviously
got to play Mass Effect for the first
time yes Babel Fable's a game that needs
to come back man we talked that got
teased a while ago or something like
that
I'm ready for some Fable again but yeah
I mean those are the games I was playing
back then and I just had the most time
to game and I was still a big fan of PS2
and PS2 will live in infamy has probably
been one of the best consoles of all
time for sure but yeah Xbox is just more
uh influential to me
it was a tremendous tremendous gaming
history tremendous selections the
legendary Todd Insight gaming in the
building love the journey love the story
you know we love hearing this kind of
stuff very inspirational content is fire
you know what I'm saying obviously you
know you have the option to stay if you
wasn't we go long you know what I'm
saying we're not kicking anybody out but
let me know if we had time so if I know
we got to take care of some bills and
stuff yeah we're gonna take this hair
the super chats and then uh pay the
bills and then we'll I'll drop my bars
on my uh on my uh topic and then I get
out of here absolutely absolutely I'll
uh I'll go ahead and uh just say it was
really awesome to be out here I'm gonna
go and get ready for Mother's Day
to say goodbye to the chat everybody is
awesome no doubt it was really cool to
get a chat with all the rest of the
Lords of the table yeah absolutely and
hopefully if you guys are going to be
out there uh because uh Cognito brought
up that you guys Summer Games Fest you
guys are out there let's get a beer yeah
absolutely
gonna link I want to put your um links
and stuff in the channel give me a
second chat so people can know where to
find you all that good stuff my man
Insight gaming news he's out here moving
that's the link to all his content
outside in these streets yeah go check
he's outside for real he's in these
conventions he's out on the streets he's
doing the content Tick Tock twitch
YouTube go hit that link go check them
out go support our brother really doing
it big and bro it was always a pleasant
man it's Luke
other guys too so sorry for ruining your
damio game last night
did that when he put his hand on my
shoulder
No Doubt
so everyone take care of business yeah
yeah and after that after soft leave no
more Super chats
[Laughter]
all right super chat ah brother oh
let's play with each other's joysticks
two dollar Super Chat I wish I could see
you stop playing with big link yo yo
yo
okay yeah I heard big link is a big
banger oh wow
so what do we do General King if XBox
bucks Up On Us in June do we store
Microsoft headquarters and tell Phil his
army is ready
oh the line
then we got one pint Johnny five pound
super chat I love that name
that's it one time much love Brothers
thank you bro appreciate it that much
love let me got zip Davis five dollar
Super Chat this is private Davis
reporting in King are we holding the
line waiting for the signal to commence
operation okay
[Music]
sup supersonic it's op major highlight
in Frontiers yes yes
yeah I'm playing Frontier the world
while he's flying it's crazy we got
necromancers they'll five dollar Super
Chat cog's goal is Chris from Resident
Evil 5. after visiting the gym he goes
up to his framed Resident Evil 5 poster
comparing biceps and goes not yet
uh he can punch a bowl there into little
pieces he ain't ready yet yeah there we
go
Todd heard the Final Fantasy 7 Battle
Theme during breaking Savage
then we have David hotwright twenty
dollar Super Chat my dad passed recently
and the funeral was yesterday he was the
one who started me off gaming on the
Commodore 64. I'm just glad to be back
at home listening to the best gaming
show IOP love you guys fam and great
guests oh David all condolences to you
for some serious condolences man for
real good to see you and like I said
shut up so we give a little bit of
support exactly yeah we can put a smile
on your face facts all that matters and
that we are done do we have like a a
poultry yeah I got a poll and I got uh
one patreon question so yeah let's do
that and then we'll then I'll pay the
transition No Doubt last week's photos
and the people have spoken with Phil
Spencer's latest comments regarding not
attempting to out console PlayStation
and Nintendo which strategy do you think
Xbox needs to adopt moving forward the
winner of the three-way IOP poll at 63
of the vote was remain committed to
Quality AAA games makes the services
more attractive group coming in at
second place at 28 of the vote will
stick to the long-term plan of play
Anywhere Acquisitions and Game Pass
model and in last place at eight percent
was the messy Lords I don't care the
Xbox Showcase in Starfield need to be 11
out of 10 group shout out to everyone in
the chat uh Lord addict uh they want AAA
games man do you agree that Jerome got
it right
yeah I mean we we knew with that we knew
that was going look I will say that it's
important to have a good mixture of both
and well you know the industry needs to
do a good better job at giving both but
it's like look at the end of the day
like people want those big experiences
and they've always wanted those big
experiences no doubt no doubt and then
we do have a patreon question we can get
now
um this is from J boogie327.
sup Lords I have a thought activity for
you gentlemen if you're willing to
indulge I've always had a fondness for
the DC Comics IP Men In Black to my
knowledge there's never been a video
game adaptation I've always pictured the
game of my dreams to be an open world
buddy cop tactical detective game like a
GTA meets LA Noire but the human NPCs
break World believability when you fail
to neutralize them if you see them
interact with aliens anyway if you guys
know the IP what systems could you see
in a game like this in what studio do
you think can make something like this
personally I think Xbox should go for it
Cog let Phil know if he needs a
scriptwriter for the project your boy
Boogie's on Deck got you okay all right
all right Boogie doing a lot today so uh
yeah any any thoughts on this song as
far as uh all right I mean there's been
a bunch of Men In Black games though
they're from the PlayStation one
PlayStation 2 era
um I never played them I can't say I've
ever played them
um so I don't know I'm just looking at
scores right here and then you know not
not very good
I think that's like the Spiderman thing
it takes that one good good good one to
really start pushing the rest so yeah
yeah I mean I don't know I I I would
think that in order to make a good game
with this IP look at something like
destroyal humans and kind of take that
sort of tone because I think that the
tones are similar even though the time
periods and stuff are different and and
do something like that obviously you
play as the alien Destroyer All Humans
but I mean that tone and that type of
action or obviously over the top action
with all the different weapons that you
have and it's got to be comedic so to me
who can do that honestly maybe maybe uh
what should we call it up what the hell
is a I can't remember the name um Tim
Schaefer's uh oh oh yeah like a double
double fine double fine double fine
seems like maybe a good fit Ubisoft
no no you want a comedy I don't want no
comedy oh you wanted straight lace Men
In Black no I want I wanted to be I
wanted to have a serious tone okay you
know um like when they erase your memory
they really erase your mind
you ain't seated
like the travesties that go on and they
keep waking up like in Groundhog Day
like not me again man and you don't
remember stuff and you got to go back
and trace your steps
I want to see a serious tone so it that
was a good question yeah yeah that's a
real good shout out I'm gonna go with my
man Lord Gene Lords gaming.net in the
building Shoney owns the Men in Black IP
oh really yep
all those games suck oh don't do that
he said there's quite the Sony red and
black room but they listen I'm rolling
with you really
don't make no Men In Black game
it's a big Big Blocks
I have to work it out
gonna work it out
continue so yeah that's it I think we're
done to anybody any any other answers
um
I don't know if attic answered yeah
I think men in Black's cool but it's
like Sony focused on something else yeah
I know you want to go Men In Black right
now because you know it's into Willis
campus oh well yeah yeah
I think no I I look look I I first off
if you make a game don't play as any of
the characters Club plays the universe
like maybe the person that started the
whole organization that they they work
for okay so do something like that I
don't think like even if they did choose
to choose those characters I don't think
Will's canceled enough where people
won't like support his games people just
Clowning them I think that's different
continue soft we got some pills and
super changes we got one more Super Chat
uh JD gamer five dollar Super Chat hold
the line and I wouldn't want to be a
PlayStation fan come 2024 by then all
will be clear takes time to bake a great
cake and this one is delicious over here
always objectives
oh wow he back he's back two dollars JD
gamer paddle paddle is Microsoft buying
WB or Netflix which which uh which would
you which which one would you want WB on
Netflix oh hold on I got an answer
all day so WB they still got what
Rocksteady
yeah WB all day they got another room so
I'm I'm in for netherreal I mean I can
want Netflix though I would take Netflix
why you want Netflix sir I want games
not look up on the service I'm looking
at global domination okay and
um just to be able to have access to
their uh user base
and instantly
um trying to win the game give everybody
three months of game pass
because that's this that's that's the
move that's the point like that that's
the play if they have I don't know how
many millions of subscribers they got
but everybody in this world got Netflix
okay okay got everybody in this world
Got Game passed okay and if you know oh
yo today you know this month we gave you
three months bonus oh so you subsidizing
you merge into Services yeah oh yes so
you can just click it as an app right
there all you got to do is order
controller so Netflix Netflix
subscribers because you're getting past
subscribers oh my God let the CMA try to
attack
it would look me in the face and say you
should have chose WB
you got to stay low we gotta we got to
go for the game stay low okay I guess to
me it's um you know Netflix would
obviously bring a lot of uh value to you
know there's absurd especially if they
like like made ultimate where Netflix is
part of it yeah like the like the the ad
one the one where you see advertisements
uh I think that would like greatly
increase the the amount of subscribers
but to me look I want games Warner
Brother guy Warner Brother got some of
uh the people who made Shadow of Mordor
one of my favorite games they got they
got they got another round Mortal Kombat
yeah Killer Instinct back up in there
like I think there's a lot and not to
mention they got rock steady and
obviously once they get all this stuff
and they they wipe their hands clean or
whatever that Suicide Squad games doing
then they could go work on an actual
superhero game for the Xbox platform and
stop letting Sony run wild with
Wolverine and Spiderman and probably
Fantastic Four next and X-Men and
they're gonna have their child
wow
[Laughter]
yo stay the hell away from nothing
that's different all right so that is
the last one I'm gonna read yes yes
what do we got going on what we have
going on is that this show is sponsored
by better help
so let me ask you guys a question
how much time do you guys spend on
yourself in any given week as opposed to
how much time you spend on other people
and then how do you balance those two
things if at all right it's really easy
to get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you while sort of never
taking a moment to think about you know
what you need from yourself but me
personally as I've said many times on
this show I work a lot of hours during
the week so I have no time for myself
and then when the weekend comes around
honestly that time is for my wife my
family my parents my nieces my nephews
my siblings and of course my family here
at the iron Lords podcast
truth about it is that it's
for me when you spend all your time sort
of giving to other people and that
there's nothing wrong with that but the
truth of it is you can feel kind of
stretched in and kind of burned out
and these are certain feelings that
therapy can help out with you know you
can find more balance in your life so
for me even though I haven't gone to
therapy for these specific things that
I've talked about I have gone to therapy
for something that I went through a long
time ago in my life I went through a
really difficult divorce about 15 years
ago and even though I was super excited
elated even to sort of get out of that
toxic situation the fact of the matter
is I had no idea how to deal with my
feelings like I had a lot of anxiety I
had anger and I just I didn't know how
to get past it in a way that was
positive for me and that would also let
me just move forward in my life and try
to find the best version of myself so at
the behest of my friends and family I
went to therapy and I have to say that
it was amazing because it taught me a
lot about sort of just figuring out my
feelings in a positive way organizing my
life and then being able to move past it
so that I can get on with my life and
sort of take everything that I learned
from those that bad situation and use it
in a positive way
so the thing about therapy that was
great for me more than anything that it
was kind of one of the things that I
didn't think about it's just the fact
that a lot of times when you think
someone needs therapy it has to be the
most traumatic crazy thing going on in
life and the fact of the matter is no
it's just about dealing with the things
that affect us day to day so if you're
thinking about going to therapy if
you're having an issue like the one I
just described you can give better help
a try so
the great thing about Better Health is
that it is completely online it's
designed to be completely convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule all
you have to do is go to the website fill
out a brief questionnaire and within a
matter of days they'll match you with a
licensed therapist now if for whatever
reason you don't feel comfortable with
that particular therapist no worries you
can go back to the site and get
rematched with a therapist the number of
times that you need to feel comfortable
without any extra cost so the the great
thing about that is beyond all of that
it's just the fact that when you're
doing it online maybe you have some
anxiety about having to go into an
office and meet someone and you know see
if you Vibe personally with them all of
this is online everything everything is
how you want it and what's most
comfortable for you to get the help that
you need so if you find yourself in this
type of situation that you feel you're
going through something that you don't
know how to deal with you've hit a wall
you're just anxious you're frustrated
you're tired maybe in order to find more
balance of your life you can do that
with better help so
with betterhelp you can go to
betterhelp.com iron Lords today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash Iron Lords
no doubt Lord solve in the building link
is in the description look man it ain't
nothing you know to to show as far as
like all of us going through stuff
emotionally you know it's our biggest
men people who struggle you don't say
like we struggle we say we do yeah that
you need something or you're going
through something that it carries when
you say yes I'm going to go get
um help like I was going to see my
therapist like when those stimulus
checks was popping yep
my therapist well you know because of
everything that happened we worked out a
deal right and I was like yo I can't um
you know do this amount you know
perception because his sessions was a
lot and he was like yo we having
breakthroughs I'm willing to cut my
course wow to to basically the bare
minimum wow and um I was making you know
my my weekly visits but I'm going to
tell you like I have a great support
system
you know these guys here are a testament
to my great support system absolutely
but at the same time they are completely
biased towards me good point right
because they are my friends and my
family yes so you know they will always
do what's in the best interest for me
and regardless to what and and I love
them for that and I love them for that
support but when you go to a therapist
that person doesn't have a horse in the
fight only your mental health and
getting you past your hurdles so it's
something to consider and you know try
not to put a stigma on yourself yeah and
the cool thing about is that I love the
fact that he said that it was online
because again a lot of people got that
stigma going into an office you almost
sit down in front of some random dude
that don't know me
so salute you know slow to better help
it's a good stepping stone you don't
have to physically go anywhere yes and
then if you feel like that's really
doing you then you know schedule a
couple in
I think this is a beautiful thing we
have to be the only podcast ever that's
going to sit there and comment on an ad
read after the reading and it's a
beautiful thing I didn't tell you guys
this but I got two DMS after the last ad
read one specifically saying yo I don't
know what it was but the read just made
me get up off my butt and my wife and I
just went into therapy and we we've
needed it forever and I was like I
couldn't believe it I read it I'm like
nah it's gotta be a joke and it's real
sometimes it's just hearing it from a
voice that you find you know whatever
you find
yeah comforting for whatever the reason
right and I I couldn't
yeah go to therapy bro yeah
[Laughter]
oh
we don't need that couch there moving
you're gonna put all the links in the
chat to it yeah links to the stripping
pin that pin at the top as well go hit
that betterhealth.com
no doubt oh we got one more Super Chat
we're going to we got uh stay high FFF
the new member five thousand yeah add
read reminded me of those late night
commercials that play all night when the
programs are done I don't know if that's
a good or bad thing but okay so somebody
said so I've got that um a serious XF
voice that's seriously yeah
okay we're gonna caught up oh actually
let me see uh no Suicide Kings remember
for 30 months Lord bronze stay low I'm
tired of COG wiping this muddy platforms
on my on my white sofa can we beat his
legs
he said if your couch
what's going on they messy they messy I
don't know who I slammed it down I got
upset but anyway so if this is yours uh
topic really get because I know you
gotta go so we're like yeah
set it up and then and bounce yeah so
yeah the rock Ally was uh officially
officially unveiled this past week to
have a June 13th launch date
um and what was super interesting about
it is how hand in hand with Xbox
marketing this uh this product is and
for all of us that have kind of dreamed
over the years of an Xbox handheld
whatever the case may be if you dream
about it in in cloud form or whatever or
just a a native sort of bespoke Xbox
device this is the closest thing we've
ever gotten especially considering that
the limitations of the steam deck uh
because of the fact that it uses
um whatchamacall Linux you don't have a
native version of game pass on there
what you what you can do is Finagle a
cloud version of Game Pass in a browser
that allows you to access your Gamepad
stuff through the cloud but again if
you're not someone who uses the cloud
like that it's not ideal either the Rock
Ally solves all of that by being by
running on natively like Windows 11 it
is a more powerful machine than the
steam deck and it really feels like it's
working hand in hand with Xbox
specifically Game Pass to sort of
be that next sort of kind of that's kind
of zeitgeist moment in in the space in a
way that I maybe without the The Game
Pass thing it doesn't achieve
um and I I find it very interesting I
was about to jump on it and then I'm
like all right
um
I just spent ten thousand dollars I just
spent yeah yeah just spent in addition
to having to buy a brand new TV with my
TV dad I was like stop being a don't
don't do it so I have not gotten my
pre-order although when I looked in the
pre-orders are still available I'm like
[Laughter]
yeah but um it is very impressive the
version that's going to be out day one
is the most powerful version which is it
has the ryzen Z1 extreme immediately it
could be the most powerful the most
powerful and expensive one right it'll
be retailing for 6.99
you can buy it in stores right well
minus 70 if you get it from uh from Best
Buy and you have the Best Buy credit
card yes yes
um and for whatever reason I kind of
feel like this has a little bit of more
oomph behind it than any other sort of
release that might not be associated
with with Xbox or any other of the big
three right this is this is big
especially for if you're in the Xbox
ecosystem and you sort of you buy into
Phil's you know the Mantra hey we want
you to plan whatever screen you want to
play right this is the ideal place
because now you're getting your game
pass PC at least yes Game Pass PC in a
native format that is powerful enough to
run those games better than the steam
deck does quite frankly so it's exciting
it's exciting and I want to know what
you guys feel about that so before I I
will I'll drop my bars real quick and
I'll pass it off to you guys I know you
gotta go I love everything about this I
love the fact that Xbox is attaching
themselves to this because I they were
never going to do if they were ever
going to do anything right and we've
already seen they're not and we've
already seen how you know the the the
backbone and the Razer Kishi stuff has
been you know people they've been
touting phone Cloud stuff right they
were never going to exactly gcloud exact
gcloud as well so they were never going
to build their own and they're going to
attach themselves to to one product or
another this is the one that feels like
it has that perfect Middle Ground of hey
it is a premium product a 700 product
but it isn't the Aya Neo which you know
I was looking at which is like 1500
right right and it's considerably more
powerful than this but it is fifteen
hundred dollars right right
and it just feels like this is if if you
really buy into the mantra I we don't
care where you play we want you to play
on as many screens as possible this is
expanding upon that in a way that I find
super interesting it's a real I feel
it's a positive W in in the past couple
of weeks of pounds you know
um and my only in it it's beef in
quotations yeah on your beef with your
beef I want them to go all the way with
it bro I wish it was just Game Pass
period forget game pass this PC game
pass dude this is The Game Pass machine
not Game Pass PC because they are still
differences although they're but just
throw Game Pass period on there if you
don't want to play in the console
anymore you do you want this just play
it
um but again I understand that is that
is jumping in right first completely
right yeah but that would be my only
quote-unquote beef with it other than
that uh you know again shout out to you
car going out there going viral with all
the stuff that you saw the number one
video I finally I finally beat you you
beat me you beat me well deserved it
took it took years this man oh my God
kingdom come Deliverance yes of the Dead
yeah yeah we did that
idea big beard in the business
um finally went viral my first one and
shout out to uh oh what's it biscuit I
forgot I forgot their name biscuit
[Applause]
but this is so well deserved because
again we we had to abandon you we
couldn't go with you that to that show
or you went out there and you did it you
asked every question like uh you it was
it was so amazing all the free all the
stuff that you got was kind of crazy and
the fact that it blew up the way it did
and nobody else had that info those
videos the way you had you had little
previews that went up from bigger
channels much you know a little bit
later it wasn't what you had I remember
looking at my timeline and when those
dropped I'm looking around to see who
else is dropping at the same time nobody
I was like oh okay and it really it
really paid off so again I'm excited I'm
excited about what this this is done for
our channel right and I'm excited about
the product itself because I think if
you're an Xbox gamer and you want to
sort of expand where you play Xbox
and you want it in a native format you
don't want to do a cloud or whatever the
case may be this is it man this is it
and it's a powerful but it's a powerful
little beast here so that's how I feel
no doubt so I'll join you anyway I know
you gotta roll I have a great have a
great Mother's Day I love y'all happy
Mother's Day
and your sister happy mother's day
tell Mama
I absolutely will tell mama no doubt
until wifey of course came and and of
course uh AJ your mom you know love
y'all I will see y'all next week no
doubt enjoy brother I'll be heading out
right after you
these are the duties
you are techno handheld
in hell you know not really into the
steam deck stuff and all this so now
that more information has come out on
the Ally you know
um Xbox's involvement like soft said you
know seems to be they retweeted it from
the Xbox account which I thought was
interesting
um you know where yet with the Ally
those guys out on it oh I already see
what we had with it
all right let's see what it is you got
Game Pass yeah no it could have Zelda on
it oh yeah well technically it could
legally yeah
I don't know about the legal part would
you want it
look it's cool but until they start
making experiences that I can only play
on that platform I don't care about that
platform you like the games on game pass
I mean
okay I have them on my PC I have them on
my uh my Xbox like I play with you when
you on the train or in the store no put
music's with me so that's fine
you can do your PC stuff you do your
editing everything everything is
straight PC and I also got this so
you can do editing this this has the
actual the actual games
you can do windows on it you can do OBS
and all that on that you can do that I
got a I got a laptop so yeah
I'm not impressed I'm not impressed no
it's cool and I'm sure a lot of people
like it's the way I feel about the steam
deck like yeah there's a lot of people
that like that type of stuff and that's
cool but at the end of the day it's like
I prefer to play the games that I want
to play on my console where I feel more
comfortable where I can sit in my chair
if I'm out and about like that like I
can see this being like beneficial for
like traveling but I don't travel like
that you know it's not your use case
it's just like it's gonna sit like my
switch has been sitting there for like
two years it feels like doing nothing
yeah because you never you definitely
excited doing nothing I feel like I feel
that I feel that Dr all day doggy doc
doc switch gang I gotta be addict with
his nonsense Lydia Bastille come on
that's his opinion and that's where he
at with it these people cap they will
sit there they're gonna post pictures
like this uh on thumbnails
don't do that don't do that don't be
disrespected after about
I would say a week of that then no one
would've done before
you're gonna see the big thumbnail with
this well it's cool you guys got
something that you feel comfortable you
know playing on the road that's cool but
don't come at me because I don't care
about playing stuff on the road
it Advocates Xbox moving on them I'm
joking I'm joking all right no doubt no
doubt Lord King Lord Ally
where we at you predicted the price
correctly yes correctly before it even
went the rumors you was on your side my
sources is legit oh you're an ADA dude
I'm just let dudes know like when I when
I spit the facts y'all gotta really tune
in and get that
so all these dudes these frauds
King Xbox needs a handheld King
Xbox needs to be in this face right here
King that phone stuff ain't gonna hold
it King
why you sound like free R Kelly
so Sony about to beat Microsoft in the
handheld space
Natty on you they in two spaces at one
time think about it this way just like
how they got the series X and the series
s they got the G cloud with Game Pass in
there too look at that and then look at
this one right here this is the series X
right here hell no Phil won't go
okay who did that for you all we do we
take it back
was the really expensive he said any
weird game passes that he had
so was that was the shelf or him having
a Rog Ally
on it and actually on a kind of funny
interview when they asked him to talk
about some positive raw he did mention
it he didn't mention it
whose box is that pause
Yo Game Pass right there all right so
this is how you get this is how remember
when I was trying to explain the people
that can't comprehend yes on an
interview he said you know great games
won't force people to switch what he
meant to say was great games alone right
like we can make great games but you
know that's not gonna move the needle
here there where we're preaching to the
choir yeah we can have that backbone and
we're gonna do that that's something
that that's a given but what we have to
do is we have to think outside of the
box this is directly thinking outside of
the box get one of the best
manufacturers and everybody kept trying
to figure out how come there wasn't game
pass on Steam how come you're not doing
that Gabe is good with you Gabe got your
back Gabe has been talking nothing but
nice things Microsoft saw the bigger
play down the road that you didn't see
the information that you didn't see two
times the power than the steam day
on the ground floor coming in
Game Pass everybody that has it gets
three months of Game Pass yes factual so
everyone that purchased that console
is a potential Game Pass subscriber Game
Pass subscriber good point once they
activate it they stay in the ecosystem
sometimes you activate stuff and you
forget about it and being that you can
download the games natively to the
console it's nuts native game pass is
huge that's that's the biggest thing
it's not Cloud it's not gcloud and
Microsoft made sure they attached their
name to that they were there too so
being that they were there in the
presentation there's Windows 11 runner
on the box yes when you went yeah you
and I we were talking man and I was I
was trying to move Heaven and Earth no
you were trying to get there you were
trying to get there there's no doubt
like I said please don't think nobody
was trying to leave cogno no family saw
trying to get there just schedule wise
and especially King he was trying to get
there but we held it down yeah man you
you I'm talking about digital thing I
just knew this one was the one you knew
it that's why you wanted to go you was
like like because you that appointment
came up he's like I'm trying everything
to be there because you knew what it was
and you've been championing this device
for a minute yeah and I knew the price
on on the bigger version
um so me saying 6.99 and it comes out
6.99 that's exactly what it's going to
be and I told you the price on a smaller
version of what that was going to be and
it's exactly what I said hi
don't be yelling dropping the kids off
in the pool
that was wild funny don't be doing that
don't be talking to me through no
bathroom
don't be talking to me from no bathroom
continue having water splash your cheeks
yo
but
this device is going to be
um
a moment
if other uh
console manufacturer video game
um developers uh decide to put their
software on a emerging console coming
out handheld console you know um
uh what is it uh Ubisoft plus you know
PlayStation yeah you know um the
potential
added Revenue added gotta check
he ready yeah it's just the potential
for growth
is immense yes and the ability to leave
no stone unturned in this fight is
exactly what you want from leadership
right they're not complacent Leave It To
The Kingdom make this about Xbox and not
about the devices oh yeah well it is a
defense Xbox is all the way outside with
this device I've never seen them go this
hard for a third you know part it's they
didn't make it like but then they're
completely invested with the launch you
know when I was there at the event
Microsoft and AMD was there like that it
was different energy with this device
now I have to give him that so it is it
attic normally I'm with you in this one
like we gotta let him Rock cause Xbox is
Phil Spencer out there with the device
on the Shelf talking about it that was
free I'm sorry
do your thing do you think God I'm
Shuffling this up man let me cuff okay
it's just it's just the fact that
everybody keeps asking Microsoft to act
like Microsoft now they acting like it
and all those things that you asking for
did you want it or was you really just
blowing smoke out your butt these
consoles are going to be available
native game native game pass inside of
handheld cloud game pass over here if
you if you want to do that
and the Machine is a Monster yeah
I think honestly
with the performance that's inside
because one video that you did when he
closed out of the game it was mad stuff
running in the background I didn't clue
how to close out correctly and I had
like three games running and it was
still handling I was like yo that was
kind of crazy so that this just shows
you uh the versatility of the machine
and you know no that's not going to be a
bait and switch thing you know I believe
exactly what he was playing will be the
retail version that will come out I just
I'm really happy uh for oxes because you
know um listen my monitor is an axis um
my laptops you know it's just you know
I'm not a PC dude so I'm not even gonna
pronounce it properly
but I know that they make solid stuff
yeah you know my Predator Series monitor
has uh withstood attempts at the time uh
my laptop Predator as well uh same thing
test of time so no I like they I like
their products and I think this was a
great product coming from them yeah no
solution yeah I'll get my bars off
um look I thought they nailed the price
I think that just being only fifty
dollars more than a steam deck ties in
is is really competitive really
aggressive I think that um you know the
thing that got me off the back was the
screen Vibrance and the fact that the
500 nits you can legit play outside
normally you can play these handhelds
outside with bright Sun you can do that
with this the freesync is huge it's
literally vrr on a headset I mean on um
on a handheld which is amazing that
smooth things out when you got the frame
issues you know Windows 11 is big now I
see the pushback from a lot of the um
you know steam that Community who are
like look you know the touch pads is a
no-go and I get it you know as far as
menus and stuff like that I completely
get it but you also got to realize that
like there's a subset of Gamers who
don't want to tweak anything
there's a subset of Gamers who people
have to understand this is why the
Casual market and Council Market does
well there's people who just want to
turn something on launch and go they
don't really want to tweak and at very
minimum they want it simplistic where
it's like okay if I press this button
it's going to be 720 if I press this
button it's going to add for free like a
lot of people just want that so to me
you know I know people like yo steam has
the history with the UI and the
interfaces and they're more confident in
that and that's valid but also remember
when steam first started the theme deck
excuse me first started like there was a
lot of things wrong with a lot of the UI
stuff that they had to iterate so I'm
willing to give the Ally a shot on that
because again the key the thing that's
given me hope is Microsoft's investment
in it because to me I got to be real
like Steve could offset with a lot of
the you know steam deck the steam store
stuff you know what I'm saying right you
know the fact that Microsoft is involved
in it the Game Pass involved with it I
don't know oh baby this partnership is
Deeper Than Rap in a sense because it's
like I'm curious to see how they getting
this or the back end obviously the Game
Pass like that I I think
um AMD broke at that deal somebody broke
it something because they they did
they're big and bad bro AMD and both of
them are there yeah
and this is uh rdna3 like yeah machine
is an animal it's a beast it's a beast
and the thing that the key again gamers
are simple you know should I play people
are they gonna say can I play against
your impact can I play Destiny can I
play if it's Windows 11 you can do
whatever you did on Windows 11. that's a
huge sell for a huge base so I think
they got it I think Microsoft saw
something in this device you know what I
mean and they're definitely putting
their you know what you call behind it
three months Game Pass like you said is
pretty much huge you know when it comes
to Hardware we got to give Xbox this we
gotta we got our issues with the games
right now but when it comes to marketing
Hardware
oh they know how to do that and the
thing that I like that they did King
is the way from the marketing standpoint
yes native game pass right but yo you
don't want to waste up your your hard
drive space right
clap with the Wi-Fi six download the
cloud version instantly I mean play the
conversion instantly almost like a test
bed see if you like it and then yo if
you like okay boom we move this over to
the to the hard drive and you download
it that's a that's the smart way to
integrate Cloud to me almost like a try
before you buy kind of thing see if you
like because just in Game Pass and not
being able to and still having that
Fidelity that's a big deal so look I
like what they're doing what we're doing
with it the key to me is gonna be
windows I gotta be real y'all gotta show
me that y'all gonna support Windows 11
needs to show me that they need to
support a mobile gaming interface making
the fonts bigger the UI nicer being able
to move around in that on the Windows
Tower so then you're worrying about
Windows stepping there that end up yeah
yeah
I'm good no no that was pretty much it
the key look I played it the Armory
crate you press it the interface comes
over shows all your games again just the
the okay also okay also the Armory crate
shows you the games that you have from
every store huge in in order but um one
of the things that uh you were talking
about with it is matter of fact just
finish finish it though get your balls
off because I don't want you to forget
well I basically did um
because the thing is again
having those presets being able to you
know hook it up to a TV hook it up to a
monitor you know what I mean again I
just want them to really dig in Windows
to dig in on handheld gaming on the OS
part because technically this is a
laptop straight up right right so you
know in order to do things sometimes
you're gonna have to you know connect it
to you know a mouse and a keyboard I
want that's the I got to give the steam
like this the advantage of the track
pads and going through those menus
allows you to get through things faster
when you have to do those stuff but as
far as you learn that from the Steam
Machines yes the fit so I have a
pedigree in that in that market and they
use that pedigree that they knew from
over there and they made it so versatile
yes there's nothing wrong with a steam
deck don't don't don't ever get this
wrong yeah there's a cool thing but but
the reason why Microsoft went with
Windows PC is because this is a PC yes
and the PC allows them a certain level
of flexibility when it comes to certain
games right like so unless us certain
other uh console makers or uh game
developers a word there uh Logistics and
their contracts in a certain manner
because some of the contracts say
console right right
PC is not considered a console right so
when that contract comes up that game
that's why certain games is on the PC
that's not on the Xbox certain games was
excluded from other people's contracts
that they had right so I think that
they're using the PC game pass is a
smart way
and let's be honest when they when we
look at the the numbers PC game console
Game Pass is kind of saturated they kind
of got to their their point PC game
passes where they're seeing the growth
so it's interesting that it's the PC
game pass version that is is there and
like I said it's key for me the
Microsoft the Asus relationship from a
software from a UI standpoint do what
they got to do but from ease of use
there is value I can play Destiny on
whatever storefront it'll launch I don't
have to worry about oh Linux I can't do
it's illegal bungees Banning it I don't
have to worry about verify from a game
standpoint people want to go where the
games are and this is a multi
platform storefront whatever storefront
you bought the game you can play it
that's a huge deal the things upgrade
and I will say this because I don't see
people out of talk about that I touched
look I got to stay deck I love the steam
deck but like I'm playing Tekken on a
steam bank and I got to be real king you
know when I'm trying to do my heart rank
I'm trying to do some of my diagonals on
that steam deck d-pad
it ain't but again I'm a fighting game
I'm just I'm just nitpicking from a game
play for my gaming Mr High to come over
and tweet so my thing I my man when I
was playing my review units there was
another oh I think it was one of the
engagement one of the media guys he was
having all this all the Ally guys had
different games on their Ally that
they're testing right so I'm looking I'm
like yo how you got Street Fighter I'm
like why is he had so I'm gonna go over
there and I was like let me test because
I want to put it through how you can
psychic World kick oh bro I'm getting
them off because I go from when I looked
at the Allied d-pad I was like oh that
looked kind of cheap I don't know just
oh look I wasn't sure because we look at
the steam next d-pad you're like all
right that looks cool I played it yours
yeah you play about right and the thing
is I tech for me I give it the fighting
game test and I'm doing them diagonals
and I'm like always coming out this is
what I'm talking about the other thing
from a hardcore gamer perspective is you
know how we got our Elite controllers
they got the truck when you could do the
dead zones and their triggers they got
gaming sensibility see again though the
part that they're going hard on the
gaming side I think will appeal to the
Casual Gamer Market you know what I'm
saying that is a huge deal and I
understand the enthusiasts and esteem
that guys were like yo I I I don't have
the ability to do all these hardcore
things I get it all I'm saying is you
got to give them time this is they
literally just dropped and what you call
it steam that did iterate and eventually
add things that's all I was saying but
look I thought it was cool you know
we'll see what happens but um I thought
it was a strong launch I think this is
going to be very disruptive very
positive
positive reviews from everyone across
the boards
I want those haters that want that
fifteen thousand fifteen hundred dollar
machine you know or or one of the
cheapest version of steam deck and I can
do that too basically yeah you know yeah
that's pretty much it so let's see what
happens you know it looks like it was
very positive feedback I seen it all
over my timeline you know a lot of
people hit me up said they pre-ordered
it so we shall see addict I need some
help with these super chats that uh Mr
Sub is not there you know what I mean
but um yeah we'll see what happens but
uh Rock Ally
um oh damn I was just hoping King for
you like I was like damn why couldn't
they drop the week before I traveled
it's like I had that bad boy on the
plane you know what I'm saying rock with
that dick
[Music]
yeah I think all right I remember I
think I think I might be good let's see
because I remember this one with uh my
man stay high and then I'm gonna start
from Man without without fear yeah I
think that's what we have got the email
saying my IOP valari pillow has shipped
oh should be delivered tomorrow can't
wait to say yeah and premium come first
cjg Hold the Line yeah alien seven with
the five dollar super trap peace and
prosperity to the moms and wives of the
Lord
he sent another additional five dollar
Super Chat balancing Harmony to all the
moms in the lives of the chat shout out
to Mama King Mama addict Mama solve No
Doubt no
another one member chat Echelon seven
again hit the like for the Lords happy
Mother's Day women are the Cradle of
simulation peace to the gods and the
earth
I think we all caught up on this and uh
attic man it's your topic you know the
one that she capping for the switch
cap it against my Ally you know what I'm
saying his big title came out man
oh what was that
yeah so uh Zelda tears of the king that
came out
I got got a couple hours into it not
really had enough time to like really
really jump into it but
I could see like drastic improvements
from the previous game you know they
kind of took the sandbox from the
original one and they're like look we
know you liked this and they saw all the
crazy stuff people were doing with that
game yeah and they're like we're just
gonna give you more tools and give you a
story to to do I'll actually say I was
surprised like going into the game uh
there there's more narrative it looks
like in this game got to stop you right
there for a second I'm glad you said
that
this is where I will bend the needle I
did like the introduction and the story
and the way it's being presented I that
was my main issue of everything I see
prior in that early trailer but I have
to give the like that part this is what
I'm talking about just just tell me why
I'm doing this explain it make it
interesting make it cool I want to find
out about this civilization all that but
I had to get those balls off because you
got I really didn't get a chance to play
too long so I'm trying to get mines in
now because I know you're about to get
in depth but thank you for saying that
because that's what gripped me in
initially so salute to see I'm not
Nintendo see switch cover that hot I'm
nice I give credit where credit is due
continue
yeah so it's kind of crazy the the
mechanics they put in this game
um I haven't really dove into it too
much I will say the tutorial island is a
little like confusing if you don't
really sit and look I missed a shrine
like I literally passed the shrine
because you need three shrines to do the
beginning it's like the tutorial three
shrines and I did the first and the
third one and missed the second one
because I didn't know it was there
salute so you know I like I like the
stuff they're doing
um I really like the ascendability it
gives
after since I missed the second one I
had to go through all of them again but
the good thing is I had that Ascend
ability so I could just go through the
mountain instead of going around the
mountain so that ability is really
transformative moving you around it it
completely changes the gameplay it's
it's really nice to be able to walk up
and know that okay can I actually get
above this by climbing but you don't
like in the original one it's like this
that do I have enough stamina to make
that job to make that climb but I know
now on this one it's like I just go
below it if there's like a little area
where I can go through I just Ascend
above it all
no doubt no doubt so again I did a
couple questions I did have for you um I
know you're still kind of early uh one
feedback I heard two couple feedback I
heard was um somebody said chores of the
Kingdom like they have you running
around doing a bunch of stuff do you
feel like that was in the game a bit or
you feel that baby overblown for what
you play so far
uh so far I do see what they're talking
about well I think what they're
referring to is there's a lot of
tutorial things they they go into very
big detail on you know if you didn't
play breath of the wild we're going to
teach you how to play those mechanics
and we have all these new Mechanics for
teasers of the kingdom and we're going
to really teach you how to do that
because there's building in this in this
game you're like you could build uh
just about anything you could really
think of I saw someone have like a cart
full of barrels and what they did is
they went on their horse
and they jumped off the horse went
through like an enemy camp and he shot
the barrels I think he killed the horse
but but he blew up like all the enemies
in the middle of it so the creativity of
the sandbox is insane because they saw
how much stuff people was doing in the
original breath of the wild and I think
the core team was like people like what
we're doing they just don't like the
fact that there's no dungeons I haven't
hit a dungeon yet I heard the dungeons
is off the chain yeah so they're like
we're gonna give you guys the dungeons
back and make it feel like more Zelda
we're going to put a little bit more of
a narrative focus on it because I do
feel like there's more narrative focus
and then I can work I've already come
across three cut scenes called story yes
three holes wait wait hold on we do we
do we doing narrative
yeah okay okay I feel like there's a lot
more voice acting in this game too yeah
than there was in the other one okay uh
though it's kind of like modern a Cheesy
story though Zelda's missing
What salute to them Incorporated like
what I like about this one is in the
original one Zelda was in the main
dungeon holding Ganon
and this one you don't even know where
Zelda is like like you go there and like
it it's it's a good game man I
all I know got that energy got that feel
dude what other questions you have I got
um so that we got a dungeon what about
one of the two criticisms for breath of
the wild was obviously this big Kai
would go back and forth with this weapon
breaking right how do you feel about
that with the with creativity and then
the other thing that people felt and I I
didn't feel this way but a lot of people
felt was that breath of the wild for his
the open world aspect that it was they
felt it was too open there's not a lot
to do in between things and baron like a
density problem do you feel one the
weapon stuff and two the density of the
world do you think they have addressed
that so I think the density of the world
still an issue to a point but at the
same time
I would say if you go back to like the
old Viking days like it's gonna look
similar you're gonna have vast majority
of areas not occupied by really anyone
and you're gonna have people doing
patrols like you see this in in tears of
the Kingdom I I don't really I don't
really hit them for that too much
because I think that is more realistic
than people act but I do think the world
feels more alive than it did in breath
of the wild sometimes I'll be going
seeing a fox just walk running around
seeing these random horses going
obviously that was in breath of the wild
but it just it feels like they took that
foundation and they didn't break it they
just built on and you know one thing I
uh as far as like the weapon breaking
it's like look if you got a sword and
it's about to break combined over rock
you know and
I don't know the extent you confuse
stuff yet okay but I'm very interested
to see it like you can fuse certain
items and make fire arrows and stuff now
so I I think I think they got something
I do and then I got I got to ask um
obviously the the critical reception
right now you know Metacritic what's
sitting at what a 96 right now I mean it
is cooking everywhere everyone's talk
switch covered in highlights everyone's
talking that tears of the Kingdom called
that but there is
some controversy and I'm seeing the
trend a little bit on Twitter and you
know basically you know some fans feel
that
um
Nintendo Community or certain gaming
communities are not keeping the same
energy with 30 frames per second I'm
seeing 30 frames per second Trend a lot
and how on one hand with Jedi Survivor
and redfall how people were Nicki get
for the performance but they're saying
you know on the other hand these same
people again now just reading what
people are saying is not saying what Cog
said I'm just video people say that they
don't keep the same energy when it comes
to Nintendo and they're Nostalgia
because there are still performance
issues but yet these same reviewers are
not commenting on that or nicking the
score how do you feel about that
they're they're 100 right you know
it feels real icky to play this game in
30 frames well I will say is it's
consistent like I do feel drops every
now and then but for the most part it
doesn't give me a headache like like
Jedi Survivor sometimes is making me
nauseous I still enjoy playing it but
sometimes it did because the frame rate
was at 60 on performance mode I believe
but it was dropping so much so
frequently it never really truly felt at
60 sure this game's 30 and you know if
you if if you do the the finesse finesse
I'm not going to say it all ah you know
yeah then you know
it's
it's one of those things where you know
if Nintendo don't approve their own
Hardware
at that point uh some people just aren't
cool playing to the six uh at 30. uh I
definitely don't like playing this game
at 30 but I've always been I go where
the games are and as much as I hate
playing this game at 30. I I will go
where the games are because I can't just
play this on something else like a guy
to play it on the screen Starfield you
said that you go no I'll go on people
see if there's a better place to play it
all go oh see this is the community he's
talking about they say somehow Nintendo
magically people just forget everything
about what they said last
hmm what it was see but there's a better
place to play and first off Nintendo
will go out there acting like all the
games
so you know they need to stop that right
off the bat so you said just because
they don't say we don't expect it from
them well Nintendo doesn't come out
there and say that so look we do expect
it from them but it's different than a
company coming out their gloatings at
their plat their console's most powerful
platform ever made and it isn't handling
games at 60. it's different one yeah
it's it's a different when you have a
series X and A PS5 and you're playing
the majority of games for the past two
years at 60 frames and you got this
random first party that comes to 30
frames like there is difference on this
if you want to play anything on the
switch man that's cat
matter of fact you getting hayachi face
for that man what happened that's that's
all cats just doing this because y'all
like Nintendo that's all that is
switches coming in hot
if PlayStation did that or Xbox did that
y'all will take the console and boot it
across all right but okay okay y'all
know it's old Hardware y'all know y'all
was Bamboozled the reason got hit the
way it was is because Zelda runs poorly
but Zelda's a really good game
out there and it would have been praised
by the majority and everyone loved it
people would have overlooked the 30. it
was a 30 on top of the underwhelming
that that game did to people all right
so so what about yeah this chat is
hilarious right now all right so I get I
get what you're saying with that so so
what about it it let's use the this Jedi
argument right
people feel that Jedi Survivor is an
amazing game that has performance issues
but in the reviews of Jedi Survivor
you'll see the performance issues
wretched and that will Nick the score
down from greatness what do you say for
the Jedi father community that say yo
they don't they just like yo y'all not
applying to save energy to us because
our joint is gave it a year material but
you you as soon as you see Zelda running
around y'all taking it back to 85 and
y'all feel it what do you say about the
surviving Community I think there's a
difference between a gun running at 30
frames and a game having performance
issues okay uh you know a game could
stay to 30 and that's exactly how the
developer played it uh Jedi Survivor
came out almost broken I was following
through the map uh sometimes the scenes
wouldn't go through I remember I was
fighting someone at the end and it told
me to do uh you know the force move up
and it glitched and I couldn't do that
there was a variety of things that
happened during my experience of Jedi
survivors
on the series X
at the end of the day look this game it
should run 60 but we're not in the
reality of that uh if anything
what do you guys at that point it's like
look do I not play the game because it's
not running at six nah just give it the
proper score so there's no way it's a 10
out of ten it's not like I'm not saying
it right it's not like I'm coming out
here saying it's it's oh man this
thing's running at six it's
I mean if you're gonna start knocking
people for coming out and not doing 4K
Ace these dudes ain't doing 4K we know
what they say anything
for sure they box ain't doing that it's
just your chalk it up is a loss the
thing uh when it comes to uh the
difference between tears of your kingdom
and Jedi Survivor I will say let's go
breath of Tears of the Kingdom runs
better you know so it's a smooth 30. the
hardest cap I've ever seen I get that I
get that but at the same time I'm not
following through Maps I'm not getting
stuck in Aries
Jedi Survivor got more bushes
in the first scene than they probably
got in the whole game all right we can't
do that let's throw the bricks on the
wall if the bricks on the wall ain't
look like Nintendo 64 smooth uh you know
how they stretch the texture yeah they
stretched the texture here's the thing
I was playing Jedi Survivor on
performance mode I felt like it ran 60
but there's a lot of times when I'm
running there's a lot of stutter I could
feel the frame rate drop into probably
40s to high 30s consistently and go
right back up to 60. those type of that
type of performance makes you get really
annoyed because it's not look at a
performance mode no it doesn't but I
don't feel that because look it might be
it might not be at 30 the entire time
but I feel like it's more towards that
than 60 dropping to 40. they need to all
for 60 days the game just feels way more
stable and I love compare it
Survivor I said you should buy it once
the uh the issues are fixed but at the
end of the day
an apple is an Apple so so King it it
adds the apples the oranges it's it's
cap the cap
stop but King are in defense of of the
Zelda ain't no defending these dudes
weak limp hardware and tell and
everybody got to be like yeah man it's
the greatest 96 meta score but what
about the dips in the frame rate well
you know Nintendo
what well well you you know Nintendo all
right what about the sparse it's the
sparse environment
well you know
I know Nintendo need to get better
Hardware
I I agree with you there's there's a lot
of that going on you know but at the end
of the day in order to get that eight
thing that you talking about the
majority of people had to score to eight
or a nine right all right but I don't
think that the issues have been running
at 30 is is Justified taking one to two
points I do you do it to everybody else
everybody get the smoke but these dudes
immune to the Smoke it's all the smoke I
don't care I'm not saying that it's not
a dope game it's a dope game great smoke
for you
yo nobody told you to wear those plaid
pants with that Lumberjack jacket oh
damn you don't look good baby so stop
acting like he look good stop over just
stop overlooking the fact that Nintendo
got on high waters
so do you try to say that they still
wearing some out of fashion thing and
nobody got the heart to tell them that
they got the hot waters on with their
frames and they perform it yo
with the patch still in the back they
got an impact oh Dr Lee Jeans King I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not rocking with
it I'm not subscribing to that I'm not
saying it's not a good game right we
gonna start talking like it is an ugly
duckling we're gonna start doing that
okay what's the reason why they go sell
shade it oh it's cartoon yeah it's an
artistic choice is what you had to do
one thing what about people saying which
is a legit thing like yo this is 2017
Hardware now you asking 2017. I thought
that Nintendo don't want to give you
something new they want to sell you
something old then they yo the result is
it is it me
or is it the resolution in the frames
the same as breath as well
when it comes to Performance issues the
the better the game is the more people
will ignore it yes the game is extremely
good and they and they are happy and
excited and playing it more than they're
frustrated people will forget all about
that when it comes to writing their
notes
this is why I gotta fight back oh here
we go I've seen people online at
GameStop let's go holding the cartridge
talk about the greatest game of all time
you didn't even play it yet
you didn't even play it yet stop the cap
like these dudes out here they this is
the greatest sound like a shot sound
like a shot against your taco he's been
saying that I've waited for this game
since the last one my my switch I
haven't played another game since the
breath of the wild they premature
Captain yeah man yo
we ain't gonna lie we ain't gonna act
like this ain't the biggest thing they
had yes
and in his head okay I feel y'all stop
going overboard with it man y'all ain't
gotta say he look handsome that would
look handsome man you know sometimes you
see somebody bring their baby around yo
yo you see the baby and you'd be like um
that's a baby you ain't gotta say the
baby look cute you ain't got six I got
Google you ain't gotta touch the baby
you ain't gotta say the baby you can
just be like yo that's a baby like that
baby doing what babies do
nobody telling them they baby ugly you
ain't gotta tell them it's ugly though
oh you gotta act like it's cute like
when it comes to this particular game
I I do think it's good I think it's
going to get a lot of uh play at the end
of the day
if you don't want to play a dirty
fairing game I definitely understand I
hate playing them too you know wait for
them to release the switch Pro switch
switch or something like it's like I
I've told people multiple times that I
continue saying it I will go where the
game is I don't care what I have to play
I don't care where I gotta go if the
game is there and I want to play it I'm
going to go there and play do I like
playing this thing at 30 frames no but
what if I tell you I got an option for
you okay
what if I tell you if you go down this
Rabbit Hole
don't do that don't get us cancer does
it take work they'll get us cancel
I'm telling you right now I just can't
stand the hypocrisy man the hypocrisy is
banana gaming Forte coming for you so
all I know is the game runs at 30 frames
per second leading in Game of the Year
votes is going to run away with the
award y'all need to ask you something
people like to eat I don't care about
that he can say anything he wants it's
leading everybody so what I don't care
about that part and don't make it it's
not ugly it's ugly baby you're supposed
to beg to be with the Metacritic people
for nobody is lying right now it's lying
it's a hard 86 man but y'all gonna sit
here no man is Zelda they don't come out
every hour so often man it's every 10
years we get this Haley Comet coming
through and all your capping cause y'all
nobody wants to be the dude to say it's
ugly though nobody want to be like yeah
that game that you love though that said
30 frames per second and we clown 30
frames per second game I see the
starches dudes they'll be like I ain't
gonna never play no game that ain't no
30.
and they cap they turn around and say
well you know the Nintendo
you are you implying that Nintendo's
influence and control and Metacritic and
are you saying that people are scared to
say that this game is not Perfection
imma say this
and I'm I'ma shoot oh you review dudes
they got it early
now one of y'all dudes was gonna say
anything wrong about that game y'all was
so happy
I got the code
all for the cold alone you gave it a 92.
you walked and then when it turned on
and you walked down the corridor and
Zelda turned the link and said you know
this Corridor is very nice
[Laughter]
I was happy I'll I'll have to bend the
knee on that yeah okay I wasn't gonna
call you out when it cut when it comes
to getting it he said that Starfield 30
you ain't doing it but you was over
there with that well see there's another
place I can play store I respect
you can play Zelda
shout out to the Rock allies great
device it's a great device it's just at
the end of the day it's like look like
if I want to play it I'm going to play
where where I have access to it and I do
think that because Nintendo doesn't do
anything you know 21st century when they
do anything 21st century they they get
all these props you know there's
definitely no denying I got a theory oh
oh Lord
what's the theory
there he is you guys don't buck up on
Nintendo oh you know Nintendo don't care
no matter what you do Nintendo don't
care Nintendo said you're not gonna buy
so what
so either you buy or you leave even if
you like it or you don't that's it that
and they are the real dudes holding that
energy you're wrong about that Nintendo
says we're going to give you Game of the
Year container type games
okay when did breath of the wild come
out
2017. all right now
all these yes
to still be 30 frames oh come on come on
all right he's right all these years and
they couldn't but at the end of the day
it's a 2017 hard Widow like we ignored
in fact this is my fault yeah
give me 60 frames I'm in that's like you
asking Genesis to wear the 61st like
come on
oh come on here we go I mean that's
that's all the hardest look I understand
you coming at them with the performance
issue but I gotta defend Nintendo on the
hardware aspect you're asking something
they're not careful now if you want to
say this is unacceptable in this dead
age that they have this type of game and
I want to play it on better like
ebonte's my core is the last one he said
look I want to play it but I just can't
do it like his PC Master he's like I
can't do it at 30 when they come out
with switch two switch Pro or whatever
I'm in okay so what is it what is it I
don't I don't even care hear about that
I'm playing it on my Pro controller on
my television and I'm having a great
time
don't care about that okay so what I'm
saying is have the same energy no no and
a lot of these I'll give you that I give
you that it's giving it bumped up scores
because you'll want to fit in I'm so
sick and tired of you guys trying to fit
in when are you gonna be an individual
and say yo the game is really dope I
really love the game but this 720 stuff
and it's 30 frames per second that we
hit everybody else with we need to hit
these dudes with it too all right but
you don't want to be the first dude to
say that I feel you on that but it's
like I said the the game it definitely
runs pretty suspect at times but it's a
solid experience look at look at if you
give people Freedom make them feel like
they're enjoying their time playing the
game yes the most broken games that's
ever been around
Bethesda got a nickname for it almost
multiple of their games your game of the
year you look at something like
um cyberpunk even though that game got
obliterated there's not a whole lot of
negative perspective around the game
itself Witcher 3 was really busted when
it came out to a degree and no one said
nothing when you look at Elder green a
lot of people talked about Alden Ray
have mad performance issues game of the
year as long as you give people a game
that people are enjoying more than
they're hating they will they will give
that game game the only thing I'm gonna
push back you're absolutely right 100
boss is on fire only thing I push
because I'm team Jedi survival and I
just didn't feel that the overlooking
was going on
right
you take the performance issues out of
all the reviews then if you're not gonna
look at this game here and say this game
is not running up to our current
standards regardless of hardware
you came outside I don't care this is
2023. I don't care if you got 2017
Hardware nobody told you to come outside
with that you go either you pull up with
a card that's capable to win or you just
back that car up and go tune it up okay
I'm not with that are you really gonna
ask do you go to that with the lambo in
a race well then they need to change
fair enough but so can't we say we know
the hugos
we know that you know baby hold up we
know that Hugo's top speed is 50 miles
an hour let's just make this up right
and they're hitting the consistent 50
with day Hugo oh right so can't we say
that it's not as a false equivalency
because Lamborghinis is known to top off
past 100 plus and say if the lambo it
get into a into 50 then we got a problem
with this track like everybody else came
on this track right
you gonna criticize my tires like I'm
going to criticize your tires so you
gonna put the lamb you gonna put your
body it'll be in this race come on
you're gonna put you go to the world
championship race circuit with
Lamborghini and talk about you go why
you ain't winning that's right you want
to be game of the year right why you
ain't 4K you want to be game of the year
right yeah why you ain't got a
performance mode
all the stuff that we asked everything
else to have we look at these dudes and
be like the exam no they're not exempt
you won't get this work just like
everybody else if Sony gonna get this
work Microsoft gonna get this work okay
it's available for you I feel you to the
letter of the law minus the capabilities
of the hardware all I'm saying is
whatever they're capable of right
if they're not hitting their capability
then yes I'm with you but if they're
hitting there 50 miles an hour AKA 30
frames per second they don't need to be
charging so I mean let's let's be honest
too like I have done nothing but speak
down on Nintendo and their performance I
came out here and said Pokemon was a
technical nightmare that was that was
disaster but this game doesn't fill that
this game look it is 30 frames but it
feels way more stable than even I said
Jedi Survivor Jedi Survivor felt very
very cluttery and feel very very
stuttery and and I get what you're
saying they do get a lot of pass just
because yeah I know what he said I know
what he's saying how much was Jedi
Survivor
oh here we go on price equivalency oh
I see what he doing now
seventy dollars
okay
am I getting okay okay I see what you're
doing am I getting seven dollars worth
okay value and you're gonna say you're
gonna say but the game solid King I I
would actually say that 50 solid I would
actually say that if you have
I would tell you to spend seventy
dollars on tears that came before you
spend 60 on Jedi Survivor and I will
look at you and say it's not gonna
happen
I mean that's cool if it doesn't happen
but I personally as much as I love Jedi
Survivor all right I think so far of
what I play the tears of the Kingdom I
really enjoyed it and also uh on
you will confirm Zelda stand yes on the
Lord and that that that's fine but at
the same time I'm a confirmed uh Star
Wars fan too
not to the extent of don't Felder if two
people go in that room Zelda in Star
Wars and only one person had to come out
you're gonna kill Star Wars right or
wrong
okay we can't take his word all right
but kick but kick in defense to add it
yeah right and you see Nintendo I'm
defending you all today I'm defending I
won't hear no sling I'm covering
respected so here's the thing
another fight when vampire survivors
came and y'all was like this is St gave
it a year and man being addict said look
at how this look and y'all was like it's
that's true it's gold over God of War
which look way Superior so who capping
that when it comes to funding and
gameplay timeout let's go
I was strategically taking God away
so we admit
the court records show that it was
biased against God wait I'm fine it's
against Sony anyway an attic is sure his
bias divorce Zelda in an amazing we
already have excuses keep in mind at
every corner throughout the years I have
done nothing but talk smack about breath
of the wild and every corner I have done
nothing but say that's a good game but
not a good zeld again we all have to
admit as Gamers we have natural biases
what up
let's go show me yo you're gonna show me
the cardboard cutouts
I don't care how many people love it
Forte it's still ugly baby
show them the sale show House move it
out there that's Zelda I don't care it's
still an ugly baby how many ugly babies
do you see in ads all day long and you
see the advertisement and be like that's
an ugly baby show that it's coming in
hot at GameStop let's go
listen man
let's go
hold on
worst looking mode
go dock it
okay it's your time I got something
different for you okay oh
come on
in that field but I want everybody to
look at that field and see nothing but
yeah okay don't do that don't be
disrespectful it ain't it ain't nobody
for miles around
you die nobody will find your body
this enemy density don't do that it
ain't no
enemy yeah you put that
that is what a game really look like
that last gen game out of here
I'll be the first one to tell you
okay but guess what what Nintendo ain't
out here promising stuff that they can't
afford they're not telling you anything
sometimes these the things you don't say
are the best things that I said oh no
hell no tell me everything
no surprises
if you assume something you're what oh
yeah surprise you're not surprised by
anything Nintendo does don't lie you
knew when it was showing up it was 7 20.
you knew it was 30 frames per second if
it could hold that
textures out just like with just like
when just like when Nintendo came out it
said 70 for one of their games I was
like hmm and people still gonna buy it
and listen we not we're not ducking that
faith we know that Faith to be the truth
everybody Nintendo Sim look at that
world did you see that one okay
guess what that world that world got
more interactions
did you put it into some splits uh you
could come from where for all you like
all I can say is 4K put it back
4K what 12 frames per second and and and
and
over time that game will get is that on
your end or my end on my end it's got
shot keep talking keep talking okay now
but um Forte yes I'm not saying that the
game probably won't be game of the year
and it'll probably be my game of the
year
We Ain't Gonna Act Like That Ain't an
ugly baby
all right
so why why don't those ugly babies views
reflect in the scoring let me ask you
King how many games have we seen that
look ugly like vampire survivors yeah
vampire survivors three dollars also
because they cheap it's okay yo don't
don't tell the truth ain't the devil
tell the truth Shane the devil hey hey
let me I made a video a long time ago
talking about Graphics over gameplay
clearly we see where King stands
bathroom's a gameplay he picked Graphics
I know him listen I know that man all my
life
hey guess what and guess what redfall is
a graphically better looking game than
uh tears in the kingdom it ain't nobody
want to play it but you know what 14
million people 14 million people have
downloaded oh so now we do it engagement
we do it listen don't punch for me
unless I send for you I got my own
statistics
King guess what 14 million people
downloaded that game and I'm with you
that's a lot of people that downloaded
it but guess what when Nintendo put
those numbers out at the end of March oh
I got the double oh the numbers is crazy
listen check this out let me let's break
let's talk numbers let's talk numbers so
tears of the kingdom is the biggest box
game release of 2023
is 173 bigger than breath of the wild
box sales 30 higher than Hogwarts Legacy
I don't care he loves it in the UK after
two days The Legend of Zelda is already
the eighth biggest Zelda game of all
time it already outsold skyward Swords
lipstick on the pig it ain't gonna
change the fact that it's a pig
so what's your
what you're saying sometime at the
before the end of this month maybe
before Microsoft even has their showcase
tears of the kingdom is probably going
to sell more pockets of the game that
people downloaded very strong yes a lot
of ugly women get married oh
a lot of ugly men get mad
because they have low expectations
a lot of ugly women get married because
they can cook
yo listen
right now switch it's cooking your
wallet
people enjoying that cooking they
covered it hot hey yeah man yo we all
doing it together all y'all dying in the
same pool together
look yeah sometimes you need your
partner that can cook some women know
how to some some women know how to
marinate a chicken exactly listen I'm
telling you this
cross the Rules of Engagement Fair okay
so I don't want to hear nobody bring up
performance issues again all right so
kick you would have been comfortable if
they'd have been like a 90 or high you
know if they would have said 80 hard 86
but can you ain't playing dude you got a
frauded
I played a little bit a little bit it's
already confirmed it's not no no no no
I'm listen fraud alert okay it could be
My Game of the Year oh I'm not saying
that I'm not saying that it's not okay
but it will never achieve a high or
score you just cut it out with the 10s
cut it out with the hundreds I'm just
I'm sorry okay I feel that I sit here
and start overlooking the fact that you
got old Hardware in the store and keep
expecting me to hold you to this high
standards okay you know you you're the
greatest Nintendo no you're not
you got on high waters and you're
looking funky out here and you need to
change it up and people been asking for
a pro for years
listen if the pro came out we wouldn't
be getting the wrong allies and no decks
I feel you all I'm saying is the sales
let's let's transition right to the
sales this is just part right with the
sales right the sales up until this
point dictated there was no need because
people were buying them like okay now
for the first time yeah so let's read
your topic
um Nintendo uh Wars of big slowdown and
switch console sales release they said
in 2017 the switch has lost much of its
momentum and they said now obviously
Sony's in um Supply they said they
expect to uh 50 to sell 15 million units
of the switch console this year it's
showing the extent of the Slowdown for
this six-year-old Flagship program so
they said that you know they obviously
they try to get it in every home but
they say sustaining the switch sales
momentum will be difficult difficult in
its seventh year president I can't
pronounce his name for akara decided on
a call he said our goal of selling 15
million units this fiscal year is a bit
of a stretch but we we do our best to
bolster demand during the holiday season
so um pretty much you know they've had
pair poor holiday performance on a pair
of uh debuts split Splatoon 3 and
Pokemon in September didn't really I
guess didn't hit their expectations as
well as Pokemon scarlet and violet in
November suggesting that the market for
Nintendo Hardware is close to saturated
the switch product family has surpassed
125 million units sold on the company
set on this uh on this website so as a
result of all this there are beautiful
numbers all our basic numbers beautiful
beautiful dominant Jim said when
PlayStation hit 125 million not enough
right so so now which leads to believe
that people think finally because
there's finally some slowdown that there
might be a talk of a pro switch or
whatever what do you say this is your
topic yeah that Pro now they gotta let
that Pro go now they gotta let that Pro
go
y'all sitting there buying up all the
stuff that they giving y'all why because
y'all don't want to tell Nintendo
obviously somebody that they already got
the all the regular 125 million y'all
everybody that normally buy finally got
a chance to get one oh y'all got one now
we all play the games all here
ain't no new buyers here so what they
gonna do they gotta bring out a new
console to get all of us back at it
again all 125 million of us the same
people falling for the same tricks
listen I'm so happy that their sales are
starting to decline it took six years
showing strong sales will have them
still doing the same BS Behavior that's
why they were able to give you this game
like this that's why addict can show you
a sparse world with nothing going on
acting like everything is happening
there's nothing happening there
but again this is going to be game of
the year they don't get knocked
sales indicate that they should be
getting knocked people but people what
it they yes they do they want a new
Switch you don't got nobody sitting
there with their old switch in their
hand right now Sam I'm comfortable with
this
I want a new Switch I need a pro I want
performance mode does performance Mode
come with a pro
thank you overstating the hardcore
desire versus The Casual design
no it doesn't it doesn't my my wants
will always reflect me yes for sure
because my dollars go to the store I
feel that my time is sitting there
playing I feel that my my uh review is
my review of my opinion
at no point in time do I really care to
hear how somebody else shoot it or
whatever your attic world energy I
respect I I honestly believe it's time
I was hopeful that the sales decline in
Hardware not software and Hardware will
send red flags to Nintendo and Nintendo
will in kind release a new machine I
feel you as I believe it's time you know
I'm with you on that you know I'm with
you on that part selfishly as a hardcore
gamer I want them to me the part the
part I'm with you on is that there's
nothing more scarier than Nintendo with
power yes Nintendo with power would run
everyone out of the game like it it just
they shoot and look salute to the hustle
because they found a pocket where the
younger generation and this hybrid move
and go away you go and come home they
found this pocket I'm so happy for the
but I'm with you I specifically want the
pro that's why I am DV I haven't talked
switch a lot of people think I hate
switch but people you gotta remember
King remember when the switch was
announced I told everybody
who wants this nobody's gonna it's gonna
fail I'm like I'm telling you Nintendo
found the pocket and I've been Lord this
is one of my favorite Nintendo consoles
of all time the only issue now is that
we're at the six year mark you know did
all the sorcery with third parties that
you could do you know what I mean a lot
of stuff is not running well anymore and
now it's time and for the first time now
the sales I'm with you they got at least
listen now before they wasn't listening
are they still selling them exactly
ain't no need for us to listen to you so
to me a switch Pro and an OLED like I
would love it and I think it's coming I
think finally we're gonna get there for
2024 if I could jump in if you get your
balls an outfits
um no look the game is you know I didn't
get a chance to play alone for what I
played it looks phenomenal it the
sandbox seems amazing I will bend the
knee on that you know what I mean I
still have to play it completely to see
where I'm at as far as the whole game of
the year talk I did want to ask attic
but I don't know if he stepped out for a
minute you know okay the question I did
have to ask because he plays he he's
finished survivor he's playing this you
know I guess the question I have for you
is
based on the Metacritic you know which
king disagrees with
do you think
anything stands a chance based on what
we're hearing now like you know
obviously you know I'm team Jedi
Survivor but final Final Fantasy 16
hasn't dropped you know Starfield has to
drop Starfield has a drop Spider-Man 2
hasn't dropped is there any chance any
of those games can compete to try to
knock it off what seems to be a foregone
conclusion that Zelda might win came
here
I would say we're going to see Starfield
um
Spider-Man yes Zelda Jedi Survivor and
maybe an indie game that's that's what's
going to be the contenders I would say
Spider-Man or starfield's the Only Hell
um no Final Fantasy 16 no that's not
that might not even get nominated wow
okay okay interesting it's because it's
like well this is a year
where you know you play that one game
that stands Above the Rest yeah this is
that year where it's like you're playing
multiple games that that are just so
good that you don't know and this is one
of those years that I honestly couldn't
tell you the rest of the games coming
out this year maybe uh maybe Final
Fantasy would be where it's supposed to
but the rest of the games are coming out
this year they better show up hard
because they're not winning if they
don't let me give my best look he's so
disrespectful shout out to talk to 80 so
tears is the best DLC man it's amazing
behave yourself I've seen you a hockey
did they acted up I see y'all seventy
Dollar Deal salute to my man's soccer in
the building I'll give you the building
look that's what I got I'll just I just
wanted to have fun with it um you know
as far as the switch console sales we
already know about that we've already
kind of talked about that I'm just
hoping that you know after the six years
of dominance now you know it's it's time
to move on from the tech girl look we
love you this thing is amazing I'm gonna
rock this out I will say if they do uh
pro version
or two would be a nice transition the
way they did from remember we had breath
of the Wild
remember and then it had also the switch
version and it would be dope to get like
a you mean the Wii uh excuse me I
apologize could we you and um it would
be dope if this is the swan song but
then whatever switch Pro or switch 2 has
the beefy version and you get a it's
almost like a rematch you don't say
version of Tears of the Kingdom would be
fine I believe all of their games are
going to have performance modes and
stuff like that in it and if they're
truly smart then they would believe in
generations and Nintendo has been real
smart with supporting their older
consoles with uh the same uh software
do you think they're ballsy enough
because we know Nintendo thinks out of
the box
are they ballsy enough to do something
completely different I don't think so
you think they know they've learned
their lesson they're gonna stay in this
pocket yeah um they know handheld Market
is their Market yeah and they no one
does the handheld market like them
factually so then they also know that
for the traditionalists the console it
could be in the house for me and addict
our um switch just stays down yeah you
guys are dock switch guys right I'm the
gold guy but for you it's on the go and
that versatility allows them to be in
every conversation I think so the only
difference they might do and I doubt it
I don't think they're getting away from
the handheld they might make
a console one that plays third parties
that's that that's that's a dedicated
Integra two engine yeah I think that I
think that you know how you saw where
they they had the base form the switch
and they have the light which is not a
dockable machine I think if they do
anything or they'll have those two still
but they'll have one that just stays at
home that you can play
okay
I get what you're saying because they
have that switch light thing that can't
dock yeah and and that thing is just a
purely like on the gold machine what you
used to call it the stand still yeah the
stand still because the game will switch
it don't switch anything
so they go okay I see what we do and
they can have the standstill plus but
the one that stays in the house don't go
anywhere
and then have the real switch something
that really switches how you gonna have
your joint go switch you know for
switching and your joint don't switch to
nothing it just stays right there in
your hand are you gonna plug it into
your TV nah this one don't do that so
then why is it a switch yeah
this guy this guy I've been dealing with
I've been fighting for your Nintendo IOP
for six years
look at me strange like I didn't change
I'm just saying the Nintendo Community
the last year has been bad at being I've
been the rider on this show for the time
Emoji was for me I used to say switch
covered it hot whenever it would laugh
it did this man the smoke is a Nintendo
they did that for you
I've been fighting for y'all
I think we get these super chats and we
cut that last topic
let's just let's just let me just go
right in right now it's so quick it's so
quick okay yeah let's go boom transition
real quick oh yeah I gotta pick a wife
look rumors out there NBA dudes just
loose my man you know grubby grub
PlayStation showcase rumors are um yeah
they said potentially you know this
month late May and the big one you know
metal gear solid uh news yeah Metal Gear
Solid remake with him rumbling Silent
Hill two maybe cold toward two what do
you think and if so
can Xbox hold the line with those
massive announcements and maybe they
even show Spider-Man people saying it
that yo this this this this show for
PlayStation might be ready
attic where you at
I've got to the point where I just got
to see an official announcement
um you know so how many times last year
did we say PlayStation gonna be in
August September October it's like at
this point the only people I'm believing
is PlayStation themselves if they do
release the time of the games then you
know we might have a similar that year
where they announce shimu Final Fantasy
VII uh it was a very big year for them I
hope Microsoft hits it the thing is is
Microsoft's got a lot in in the Arsenal
they could use it just are they willing
to show stuff and I think this year
Microsoft show stuff okay quick question
before I had to Decay The Talk also is
if these exclusive deals do happen right
Metal Gear Solid 3 remake solid Hill 2
Kotor two you know for all PlayStation
there's a talk right now this is split
the Xbox community that some are saying
they need to match that energy with
exclusive deals and then some are saying
no that's not the business I could be
like game passes is the flow addict do
you feel if these things happen
Microsoft should do the same and lock
down exclusive deals for themselves yes
because Game Pass is the show but we see
that uh you know
but not a whole lot of growth in the
console market for a while PC's growing
more than cons the console Market Game
Pass subscribers uh the only thing going
to bring people into that is is content
and if your content's not ready other
people's content is right and you got to
go in there and drop that bag and I get
it
they don't do that they don't mess with
stuff that they don't own maybe it's not
necessary now because their games are at
The Verge like Phil Spencer said we're
almost there I mean regardless if you
believe or not right but here's the
thing just because you ain't willing to
do that doesn't mean you're competition
ain't willing to do that and if you sit
around looking at just your stuff you
turn around your competition bought all
the other stuff okay so
yes and I'm not even saying everything
it's like you know you see something
that looks promising it's kind of like
the 360 era you know uh Mass Effect
um Bioshock you know the these games
look promising and they took a they took
a gamble on them uh Microsoft needs to
be more aggressive and stuff like that
you know you you shouldn't be losing
everything under the sun to PlayStation
when it comes to timed exclusives
Castlevania is rumored right now Metal
Gear Solid Silent Hill sure it depends
on the studios making these games
they're gonna even be good games but
just the perception imagine if all three
of them are famous and then it's going
to look bad it's like okay now then
these aren't small games these are
iconic titles that's been in the gaming
industry for decades and Playstation
might have all of them exclusive to
their platform and then the rumors of
the fighting games
um you know Mortal Kombat you see Tekken
outside Street Fighter six so you saying
exclusivity or at least marketing rights
there
yeah um I think they just need uh to buy
another room and make Killer Instinct to
be honest with you I think you're not
going to compete with PlayStation in
that area because they ain't going Evo
oh yeah uh but but I do think that you
can you you can knock on the door and
say we got one of the hottest fighters
on the market right now and you got to
let me voice it's not whether or not you
want me in evil you got to have me you
need that checking I heard you heard me
but dude it's a kick me oh wait maybe
maybe do something where you know you
work a deal out them and you know they
put Master Chief in the game or
something oh exclusive okay I see what
are we doing we're doing that so energy
okay
um Lord King where we add PlayStation
showcase room is very juicy very spicy
it's true
you know it's gonna be crazy yeah yo
yeah on the 25th it's gonna be bananas
y'all dudes are gonna be treated to a
fantastic PlayStation show I ain't lost
podcast is going to be doing a live
reaction to it like always do yeah
they're gonna have all those Konami
bangers every last one of them the ones
that we remember and you guys never got
a chance to play and you guys are gonna
get a chance to play it certified hits
so if you have a Playstation or Xbox and
a PlayStation or a PlayStation and an
Xbox which most of us all of us here
mainly have multiple consoles
um
so what oh here we go so what uh-huh You
Don't Own It B so when she up she up oh
we get her and we gonna put her in case
or 35 minutes I don't care how hot she
gonna be hot later
on
ain't nothing nothing lost
what's old to you is new to me oh
wow yeah wow so I must say imma say have
a great show have a wonderful show go
spend that money lock them down the more
money you spend on other people's stuff
trying to do all the spicy stuff the
more your stuff in the background ain't
getting ready and you closing down all
these Studios and doing all this stuff
and while these dudes is building up
their arsenal when those blows start
coming pause and you can't get up and
you reaching for Konami shoulder and the
deal and ran out and it's in Game Pass
and you look over and what's in Game
Pass will never
go to you oh come on hey guys I gotta go
and you're ready for this dinner
I'm talking I'm talking about
it no doubt catch you later I'm talking
about exclusive Triple A
Microsoft stuff we know exclusive AAA
Sony stuff ain't never coming to Xbox or
me saying that is what that's
disrespectful that was just common
knowledge you're never gonna get it but
once all those Studios is ramping up and
all those games is coming out
how many deals you gonna keep buying
before you just start investing in
yourself and say forget them let them do
what they're gonna do Phil Long looked a
long time ago and said that's not the
way okay
you know what he did he lost the
marketing rights to Call of Duty
let's go buy them
um
so we own them okay so we ain't gotta we
ain't got to spend no money on marketing
rights we ain't got to do yo stop
acting like an employee and acting like
a boss guy
you got employee thoughts you want to
work for a check instead of going
earning this money
when that game is available everywhere
else that's diminishes the value okay
hot one day
you're talking about the long game yeah
all right then when I get it okay I'll
show you what I do but can you all right
I feel you with the with the ownership
part right like can you not miss out on
what's popping like no that's that's
those these idiot dudes that need to be
in in the know ledge all right
say fair enough what about you said Game
Pass right right have both how come we
can't utilize game pass the way they did
without writers they're doing it with
lots of P right so all I'm saying is if
there was a way probably you can't do a
Mortal Kombat is too big right but like
whatever is hot like can we get your
name again they're doing it okay like
they're they're actively going out
getting games putting them in game
passes
that stuff is happening ain't saying
like it ain't happening but I'm not
gonna lose my crap over uh konami's
portfolio being uh sold to the highest
bidder I get that but my thing is when
you lose out on marketing rights
sometimes like look at Hogwarts
perception is is that game only exists
on Playstation me and you both know Xbox
got it is right there but the masses
think that's only you could get it
that's what I'm saying like what about
would you would you not be willing to
eat forget the exclusivity right would
you not be willing to pay for some
marketing rights
no so if it's not a game pass no because
if it comes at the cost of Me closing
Studios down because of my budget is not
robust enough oh man you know then it
forces me into a situation where it
speaks the famine okay so you say these
dudes just frauded their money don't
look right under the light oh man they
close the studios Okay because they're
sitting there talking about yeah man we
doing all this we doing the biggest the
baddest we got all the console sales we
selling all the games we're laying off
everybody
[Applause]
I see how you move but we got we got
money detectors on you so on one hand we
selling all these consoles we throwing
it up in the club
we closing pixel opens and we shut down
studio so that that's the wreck that's
the day-to-day money yo you go to the
club and you sitting there like oh we
popping yo this club does so much every
night yo let me get a shot of Remy
they continue to do the same metrics
they continue to do the same things
because there was winning doing that
before
but you know how when the dude is
rolling up the bolo Punch Yeah and
you're still dancing with your little
feet thinking that move gonna work he
winding up that bolo punch
red four was the bolo punch yo you hit
the with the imaginary players you got
flash down vatava reveal buddy
I can't feel the whole thing yeah
with the money phone and doing all this
stuff
that was dope I give you these I give I
give you a homo right there so you cool
as long as this game pass related yeah
about what they do over there they don't
own it they don't own it you know they
can keep on spending money to keep stuff
off of it and when all this information
come out we know who you are man you
that dude that don't own nothing and
selling everything we got you we we
gonna box you in a corner
and it's curtains
and when it's curtains y'all don't see
that's why that hold the line went so
viral yeah it did I don't care what they
do on their show you cannot stop the
inevitable and it's over for you the E
you gonna do what the EU gonna do when
that happens watch me you would be a
very well yeah I know you gonna be out
of pocket if this goes down when we get
that Call of Duty when we get that Call
of Duty in the headlock
I want to see how you hold the line
you may holding the line at all
I can't win it I miss it knocked up
walked up after the game money I got
bail money double Excel money you got
flash now the top reveal money not the
imaginary player that was Ill hope is on
it always on it so look we gotta get
these super chats get a bone out of here
cause King is out of pocket I really
have too much to say on it just like yo
just want to see what they do
um I'm very curious about the uh
Spider-Man if they show that joint and
I'm very curious if they the marketing
deals or if they're exclusives all the
way so we'll see how that go
um
let's see Sony told you out of their
mouth there's no more AAA titles coming
this year all you getting is Spiderman
so whatever the hell they showing you on
the 25th you're not getting it anyway so
see that
can't
with that for the rest of the year
they told you nothing else anyway let me
get a couple of these Joy sorry I
apologize if I miss some people
um Lloyd Metroid two lots of Super Chat
uh Tis the kingdom will run at 60 but
it's polished to a shine no doubt astral
parrot King the homie two thousand chat
at least these Nintendo games are
actually good
shots Nintendo Taco following Super Chat
Elden ring look worse than every game on
the games of the year list had
performance issue and was broken on PC
and still scored at 96. that was King
game cap
okay
he said he said Elder ring looked better
but worse than every game on the game of
the year let's have performance issue
was broken on PC still scored in 96.
that was King's game cap
yeah it was it was my game it didn't
look like uh Zelda
don't you don't you don't man fix your
mouth man you talking to me do you see
that dragon that pulled up dragon will
crash your whole game not one dragon
with dragon yeah imagine having that one
Dragon you and a horse
eat it
2017 Hardware 2023 prices this is a
sickness he agrees shout out to the
homie hockey 200 Super Chat I'm playing
tears of the Kingdom at 4K 60 sir sir
where are you playing that at uh you do
that sir no I'm not gonna acknowledge
where you're playing that fly guy two
dollar Super Chat the name Zelda alone
gets it a nine wow okay that's your
problem that's I don't care what her
name is she gotta perform oh I don't
care I feel that so so you guys keep
overlooking just because of the name on
the box that's how you get bamboozled
and Hoodwink man come on man come on
why we only do this here in our medium
you will never order a uber black and
they pull up in a Hugo and you hop in
and everything's fine are you paying the
same price yeah he doing it yeah you
want that Escalade why is this car here
y'all just cap for what you love and
it's good I feel that I feel it demure
mathad Civic with the five dollar Super
Chat the switch had an outdated software
since the console launched the Xbox has
the world's most powerful console and
yet it has trouble going 60 frames King
out of Doom doing
what's up like
I can put bar for bar game for Game up
against your game your game is going to
look exactly like what it is and you
know what it is and you're gonna say
this is ugly baby
baby and here we go stay stay high FFF
to ten dollar Super Chat Nintendo chose
to make the switch with inferior
hardware and leave it for seven years
just because the game runs on Hardware
it was automatically a 90. I call Cap so
he agrees with King thank you Stitch uh
with the five dollar Super Chat cop stop
saying that it's 2017 Hardware when they
are charging seven dollars for a 720p
game let's keep it a hundred they should
not beat that should not be an excuse
all right there you go he disagrees that
people are having fun
no reviewer gave lower scores to DS PSP
games for not performing like the
GameCube I think gcn and the PS2 it's a
handheld and the score is scaled to the
hardware more cap King thank you okay
that's that's what you got for that I
mean listen he can sit there and say
whatever he wants to say you're making
excuses for this ugly baby
I want your ugly baby around the
restaurant
so we we gonna see your baby how we see
him in the park
that's cool keep your ugly baby over
here
get it
yo that's wow increase that ugly baby
energy
to the kingdom ugly baby Angry hippie
but honestly with jazz Skyward Sword HD
Metroid dread and Prime remastered all
60 I guess 60 FPS why not tears of the
Kingdom I mean it's an open world a lot
of times you gonna fall for it that's
why it's a lot of sandbox you know let's
see hoggy Shanique following Super Chat
Nintendo should follow other platforms
and release their games on PC King
disagree with you on this one games
should rate based on the game not the
tech
then don't bring up the limitations of
the Texas that's inside the game any
time in the review this see y'all are
missing the point
stop bringing up performance issues in
every game but this one okay fair stop
bringing up resolution in every game but
this you only capping because it's
Nintendo and you're happy I got a review
code
everybody no one's having fun though the
other dudes nope nobody wants to come
out y'all it's like y'all sitting there
drinking the dirty Kool-Aid and y'all
all smiling it's good yes
with a happy sad face you know it tastes
like doo-doo oh man do you like darn
thread I can't pronounce the currency
sck I'm sorry my brother that Lambo talk
already reminds me I saw an addict
yesterday driving is hashtag IOP money
is kicking we are not boiling like that
but salute to you for pocket watching
sagging sagging that sack is back with
the five pound Super Chat honestly
Nintendo is the biggest Con in the
industry how is this game 70 bucks and
what's up with the reviews no way this
game is 96 no way damn
going hard all right some new ones came
in I'm trying to refresh y'all you gotta
bear with me there's no so I'm out here
don't give me a second oh hold on hold
on let's just refresh to see you and I'm
just running support he's running
support right now all right so we got um
the Raiden blade five dollar Super Chat
are these games not on five pounds per
chair are these games not original PS1
games nothing new these games don't
matter because they have always been
associated with PlayStation and not Xbox
or maybe because
um they talk about the exclusives let's
talk about this showcase okay okay
talking about those games in the
Showcase so this is why I'm trying to
tell people
they are Contin the only reason why
they're purchasing those games is
because it will be detrimental to the
Sony brand for those games to launch day
and date on the Xbox and these games
have been normally associated with Sony
okay
that's what you're saying shout out to
the homie black boxing Kings we know who
you are that's the only shout out to him
my guys congratulations he got the
joysticks salute you already know and I
think the last last one for Stitch with
the five dollar Super Chat the steam
deck can increase your fun in that ugly
baby game and it's not going to destroy
your eyes it's he said how about that
car laugh have fun boys I don't know
what you talking about about these other
places to play Zelda knows I'm act like
I hear y'all Hollywood rolls two dollar
Super Chat thank you King Zelda tears of
the fried retina okay
[Music]
listen I can't do everything host the
show this is where everybody helps out
it does what they got to do so look we
gonna move on you know what I'm saying
and that is it we got um the pole and
then we're gonna get up out of here
anything that we missed we'll get we
apologize
he's gonna do the poll and I'm going to
talk about the console because we hit 15
000. so we will be giving away a console
um we're going to figure out how it's
going to go most likely it will be
patreon based all right so understand if
you're part of the patreon you know
what's inside the patreon and it will be
patreon based uh more than likely
um and it's going to be a raffle and
then you know whoever wins will
definitely pick whatever console that
they want so if you want to switch
um
oh we lost King no you didn't lose oh
you freaked me out like I'm like yo I
thought we crashed the stream you're
just cloudy I said if you want to switch
things out there if you want to switch
[Music]
you know uh just just go get something
nice but a little bit we hit 15 and I'm
so proud of everyone yeah super proud We
hit that 15 bro like it's lit um want to
get this pole and we get out of here
with the X Jagger like this it's clearly
related with the extremely positive
reception for Zelda tears of the kingdom
do you feel Nintendo gets up I knew he
was gonna go this way Nintendo gets a
pass for performance in their AAA titles
the choices are a no switch is older
Hardware never touted power and the
quality of the game is Paramount King
B yes switch is not held to the same
performance standard with review scores
as they can I predicted what you was
going to say I'm late and see I don't
care I thought we was boycotting 30
frames per second thank you I'm about
them though you're about those let them
dudes win messy Lords
no doubt shout out to the left shout out
to the cops that's going by again salute
to my man Todd Cruz inside gaming if you
missed it go catch your story super
inspiring super dope he's outside and
we're going to see more from him in the
future salute to everybody on this
Mother's Day that's pretty much what I
got you got anything to say to the
people you know what I'm saying I see
you in there what's up uh Monday uh we
should have some news yeah
um it would dictate how messy I'm gonna
be facts and look for the record if you
and your feelings about holding lines
that says all we need to know about you
the day they feel it's about I love I
love them yeah yeah I love I love that I
pushed you to the brink yeah let my
brother do his numbers man let my
brother do his numbers let's stop hating
we all having fun it's gaming it ain't
that serious but at the end of the day
it's funny and look if Kim if King is
right y'all gonna hear it
hold the line was crazy when it hit duck
a salute to everyone body you know who
have fun with it I want to represent the
positive too yeah we're positive
remember I don't look around smacking
people I just smack people back yeah
you do you know what I'm saying don't
put your hands up if you don't want to
fight anyway behave yourself look
everybody enjoy your Sunday Happy
Mother's Day we are out of here peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign